programming throwdown episode 108 Kotlin take it away Jason hey everybody super excited to do a duo episode. We've done many interview episodes with the two of us and one or more guests. We've had so many of those. And we have so many really exciting interviews coming in the future. But this was a time where we really wanted to do a duo episode.
Programming Throwdown 第 108 期：Kotlin，Jason，开始吧。嘿，大家好，非常高兴能录制一期双人节目。我们之前做过很多访谈节目，都是我们俩加上一位或多位嘉宾。我们做过很多这样的节目，未来也还有很多非常精彩的访谈。但这次我们真的很想做一期双人节目。
And super excited to talk about Kotlin. So it's an OG style. Yeah, that's right. It's an OG episode. Yeah, hopefully we'll have more time to do these in the future. We are looking at ways that we can be more productive and get out more episodes. There's definitely, we've had a lot of really exciting requests. Actually, Kotlin is a request. So thank you so much for requesting kotlin i think it's a great suggestion we've had requests you know believe it or not we've never done ada and that really surprised me so yeah we had a request for ada come in
非常高兴能聊聊 Kotlin。这是一种 OG（元老）风格。没错，这是一期 OG 节目。希望未来我们有更多时间做这类节目。我们正在寻找提高效率、多出节目的方法。我们确实收到了很多非常令人兴奋的请求。其实，Kotlin 就是一个请求。所以非常感谢大家请求 Kotlin，我觉得这是一个很棒的建议。信不信由你，我们还收到过请求，说我们从来没做过 Ada，这让我很惊讶，所以是的，我们收到了关于 Ada 的请求。
recently we've had a whole litany of requests and um and we do take those super seriously we love to do them and this is an opportunity to fulfill one of those. And I'm hoping we can do more of our OG shows along with our awesome interviews in the future. So I think if we were like one of those cool YouTube channels, we would claim we got an intern who did all this for us. Yeah, exactly. Yeah, we need an intern.
最近我们收到了一连串的请求，我们非常认真地对待这些请求，我们很乐意去完成它们，这是一个实现其中一个请求的机会。我希望未来我们能在精彩的访谈之外，多做一些我们的 OG 节目。我想如果我们像那些酷炫的 YouTube 频道一样，我们就会声称我们雇了一个实习生来帮我们做这一切。没错，正是如此。是的，我们需要一个实习生。
Try to come up with an imaginary name for them. And then, okay, anyways. Yeah, we should definitely have... a lot of interns are sven for whatever reason there's uh two of the podcasts i follow have interns named sven so that i think that's that's what the intern name has to be okay fair enough all right so if your name is sven reach us at programmingthrowdown at gmail.com so yeah i wanted to to talk a little bit in our intro topic on this thing called the gold standard. As most people know, I'm really into economics. I'm not so much into investing and those kinds of things. This isn't investment advice or anything like
试着给他们想一个虚构的名字。好吧，总之。是的，我们绝对应该……很多实习生都叫 Sven，不管出于什么原因，我关注的两个播客都有叫 Sven 的实习生，所以我想实习生的名字就得叫这个。好吧，有道理。好的，如果你的名字叫 Sven，请通过 programmingthrowdown@gmail.com 联系我们。好的，我想在我们的开场话题中聊聊“金本位”这个东西。大多数人都知道，我对经济学很感兴趣。我对投资之类的东西不太感兴趣。这不是投资建议或类似的东西，
that, but just the economics and just how money was invented and how people exchange things. And all of that, I think is super, super interesting. We've talked about it on past shows. And so on the perimeter of that is this idea called the gold standard, which is really interesting. It's this idea that you could, that all the money was backed by gold And you could literally take a $100 bill, go to a bank or go to a government institution, and they would give you a chunk of gold for it. And that that exchange was fixed. So in other words, the price of gold didn't change. The money is the gold. And so at any time, you could go from gold to money and back at a certain amount that was fixed. And yeah, I think that whole thing is really,
只是经济学，以及货币是如何发明的，人们是如何交换物品的。所有这些，我觉得都超级超级有趣。我们在过去的节目中讨论过。围绕这个话题的一个概念就是“金本位”，这非常有趣。这个概念是说，所有的货币都由黄金支撑，你可以拿着一张 100 美元的钞票去银行或政府机构，他们会给你一块黄金。这种兑换是固定的。换句话说，黄金的价格不会变。货币就是黄金。所以你可以随时以固定的金额将黄金兑换成货币，反之亦然。是的，我觉得整个事情真的，
really interesting. And it really, it kind of blows your mind when you think about, you know, what would they call now fiat currency, which means that, you know, the government kind of forces everyone to use the same type of currency. And just that forcing function is what gives the currency its value. I always thought one of the interesting parts about the like, I guess, commodity backed money was and maybe it's an extreme thing is what would happen if someone would have found like in a giant deposit of gold somewhere, or, you know, let's talk about like mining an asteroid.
真的很有趣。当你想到现在所谓的“法币”时，这真的很让人震惊，这意味着政府强制每个人使用同一种货币。正是这种强制力赋予了货币价值。我一直认为商品本位货币的一个有趣之处在于——也许这有点极端——如果有人在某处发现了巨大的金矿，或者，我们谈谈开采小行星。
And all of a sudden you like 10x the amount of gold available. All of a sudden you would have, you know, now people with fiat always worry about inflation, which is very real concern. And I don't know if that gets into a little bit of a touchy topic. But I mean, I guess like when, where America now is, the USA is like, I mean, there was a lot of gold here. And so the amount of gold sort of available in the world went up dramatically.
突然之间，你让可用的黄金总量增加了 10 倍。突然之间，你就会有……现在使用法币的人总是担心通货膨胀，这是一个非常现实的担忧。我不知道这是否涉及到一个有点敏感的话题。但我的意思是，当美国现在所处的位置，美国，我的意思是，这里有很多黄金。所以世界上可用的黄金总量急剧上升。
And a lot of the motivation for coming here was people trying to find gold. I always thought it was interesting that in one way, like you point out $1 equals some amount of gold, call it one ounce, it wasn't maybe $100 was an ounce. Sure. You know, some amounts that fixed exchange rate, but in practice, like the amount of gold is always changing and the government doesn't have direct control over the amount of gold in circulation. Yeah, it's wild. I also actually, I'm really glad you brought that up. That was the first thing I thought of too.
来到这里的一个很大动机就是人们试图寻找黄金。我一直觉得有趣的是，一方面，正如你指出的，1 美元等于一定数量的黄金，比如一盎司，也许不是 100 美元等于一盎司。当然。你知道，某种固定的汇率，但在实践中，黄金的数量总是在变化，政府无法直接控制流通中的黄金数量。是的，这太疯狂了。我其实很高兴你提到了这一点。这也是我首先想到的。
And this is what I think. And I've talked to a bunch of people about this and heard a bunch of different opinions. But my take on it is, yeah, if an asteroid full of gold was to strike the Earth, what would happen is the price of everything else would go down, I think, because there would be a lot more gold. Oh, no, no, sorry. No, the other way around. The price of everything else would go up because there would be a lot more gold.
这就是我的想法。我和很多人讨论过这个问题，也听到了很多不同的观点。我的看法是，如果一颗充满黄金的小行星撞击地球，我认为其他所有东西的价格都会下降，因为会有更多的黄金。哦，不，不，抱歉。不，反过来。其他所有东西的价格都会上涨，因为会有更多的黄金。
Gold will be less valuable. That's right. And that would make the dollar less valuable. You'd get inflation. You'd need more dollars to buy everything else. Yeah. And similarly, gold is used to make circuit boards. And so when the circuit board became a commodity, at that point, the price of everything would go down because people
黄金会变得不那么值钱。没错。那会让美元变得不那么值钱。你需要更多的美元来购买其他所有东西。是的。同样，黄金被用来制造电路板。所以当电路板成为一种商品时，那时，所有东西的价格都会下降，因为人们
needed the gold for something else that they didn't before deflation okay yes it's kind of wild to think about it's like oh this person invented the circuit board and that means like the price of milk has to go down the price of everything has to go down yeah i feel also like governments being able to change money like is in some ways like good and bad. Like if they were trustworthy, I guess it'd be really good. And the reason for saying they're bad is mostly at least from my reading is if you believe sort of like the people running government can't be at some deep level trusted. And so you don't have a trustless money system if you have fiat currency, because the government can just declare what the value of the piece of paper is at any time by printing more, or, you know, I guess taking it away. And there's always printing, I guess it can be now just like a database entry in, you know, in big banks or from the Treasury or whatever,
需要黄金做其他以前不需要的事情，通货紧缩。好的，是的，想到这一点有点疯狂，就像“哦，这个人发明了电路板，这意味着牛奶的价格必须下降，所有东西的价格都必须下降”。是的，我也觉得政府能够改变货币在某些方面既有好也有坏。如果他们值得信赖，我想那会非常好。说他们坏的原因主要是，至少根据我的阅读，如果你认为管理政府的人在某种深层面上不可信。所以如果你使用法币，你就没有一个无需信任的货币体系，因为政府可以随时通过印更多的钱，或者，我想拿走它，来宣布纸币的价值。而且总是在印钱，我想现在可能只是大银行或财政部数据库里的一个条目，
it doesn't have to actually be the classic, I guess, whatever the meme of the money printer going off. Like it can literally just be like a change of a value in a spreadsheet somewhere. Yeah, yeah, it's so true. Yeah, I think, yeah. So, you know, I think the gold standard has some serious issues.
它不一定非要是经典的，我想，无论印钞机启动的梗是什么。它实际上可能只是某个电子表格中数值的改变。是的，是的，太真实了。是的，我想，是的。所以，你知道，我认为金本位有一些严重的问题。
And it's a lot of the things we talked about that, you know, people would find gold out West and then that would cause prices of everything, all these like nth order effects to happen and prices of everything to go out of whack. Also, the government would hedge so they wouldn't actually have enough gold for every dollar in circulation. They would actually take risks on the standard itself. And so then when there was the Great Depression, I think this is actually what killed the gold standard. And I'm not a history buff, but this is just from reading this one page, that there was basically a bank rush for people to exchange their dollars for gold.
我们谈论了很多事情，比如人们会在西部发现黄金，然后这会导致所有东西的价格，所有这些 N 阶效应发生，导致所有东西的价格失控。此外，政府会进行对冲，所以他们实际上没有足够的黄金来支撑流通中的每一美元。他们实际上是在标准本身上冒险。所以当大萧条来临时，我认为这实际上是扼杀金本位的原因。我不是历史迷，但这只是从读这一页得来的，基本上当时发生了银行挤兑，人们要把美元换成黄金。
And there just wasn't enough gold for people to do that exchange because the government wasn't really planning on that. And then that caused all sorts of other issues. Oh, man, we're going to get into fractional reserve banking and what problems there are with that. This is going to go deep. I don't think we're ready for this. Yeah, I think maybe we'll put a bookmark in it. But I just thought the idea of the gold standard was really interesting. This idea that... And actually, when we talked about this kind of economic stuff, maybe a year or so ago, I had built this little simulation. And in the simulation, I couldn't really get things to converge in a meaningful way
而当时并没有足够的黄金供人们进行兑换，因为政府并没有为此做准备。然后这导致了各种其他问题。天哪，我们要讨论部分准备金制度以及它存在的问题了。这会深入下去。我觉得我们还没准备好。是的，我想也许我们会先搁置一下。但我只是觉得金本位的想法真的很有趣。这个想法……事实上，当我们大约一年前讨论这种经济问题时，我建立了一个小模拟。在模拟中，我无法真正让事情以有意义的方式收敛，
and um i actually went back to that simulation you know it's awesome that that we have github nowadays and i could just do that i went back to the simulation and i just fixed the price of one thing and then that made everything everything else so much more stable and it kind of makes sense like like if you think about it, fiat currency, there's really nothing preventing the government from just multiplying everything by 10 or dividing or decimating everything. And, and so in this simulation, which, you know, was, was, you know, very simple, you know, that that's basically what happened is things were just wildly out of control, but then like pegging the currency to any of the one items caused everything else to become stable. And yeah, so that was actually pretty eye opening.
而且我实际上回到了那个模拟，你知道，现在有 GitHub 真棒，我可以那样做。我回到了模拟，我只是固定了一样东西的价格，然后这让其他所有东西都变得稳定多了。这很有道理，就像如果你想想看，法币，真的没有什么能阻止政府把所有东西乘以 10 或者除以 10。所以在这个模拟中，你知道，非常简单，基本上发生的就是事情完全失控了，但将货币与其中任何一个项目挂钩，其他所有东西都变得稳定了。是的，这确实让我大开眼界。
And yeah, I mean, we'll have to see what happens with, you know, our episode one topic, you know, Bitcoin and all of that and where all of that goes. I know it's going to be a wild ride. Definitely no investment advice, but I'm just curious to see what's going to happen. Yeah. I mean, this conversation is something that with sort of countries the world over trying to understand how to economically stabilize their economies in the face of all the fallout from COVID has been very interesting to see that everybody's different take on whether what they're doing is a good thing, a bad thing, whether it's ruining the future, or whether the future has been saved because of these actions. It's really hard to know because it takes so long to figure
是的，我的意思是，我们将不得不看看我们的第一期话题，比特币以及所有这些东西会发生什么，以及所有这些走向何方。我知道这将是一段疯狂的旅程。绝对不是投资建议，但我只是好奇会发生什么。是的。我的意思是，这次谈话是世界各国在面对新冠疫情带来的所有后果时，试图了解如何从经济上稳定其经济，看到每个人对他们所做的事情是好事、坏事，是正在毁掉未来，还是因为这些行动拯救了未来，有不同的看法，这非常有趣。真的很难知道，因为需要很长时间才能弄清楚。
out. And in the meantime, you get so many other policies that impact what gets decided and what gets done now. So you're never doing this, like only change one variable at a time. It's like some very sophisticated running simulation where there are winners and losers, except that it's people's lives and welfare. Yeah, yeah, exactly. There's no counterfactuals. It's really hard to run an A B test. Maybe like at the country level you can, but even then. So onto the news to take a hard pivot. My pivot. My first news item was a little bit ago, the Raspberry Pi, I guess it's the foundation? The Raspberry Pi people released the Raspberry Pi Pico. So most Raspberry Pis before this,
与此同时，你会有很多其他政策影响现在的决定和行动。所以你永远不会像这样，一次只改变一个变量。这就像某种非常复杂的运行模拟，有赢家也有输家，除了这是人们的生活和福利。是的，是的，完全正确。没有反事实。真的很难进行 A/B 测试。也许在国家层面你可以，但即便如此。那么，进入新闻，来个大转弯。我的转弯。我的第一个新闻是前段时间，树莓派，我想是基金会？树莓派的人发布了树莓派 Pico。所以之前的树莓派，
which I think there's been, I think they're up to like fourth version, and then there's several variants along those. They've all been about running linux and being a full sort of almost like a computer like a mini computer right you they have video output they have sound output it's really meant to be a very sophisticated system on a board a single board computer i guess is the the term you would use yeah i mean i bought a k kvi yeah kvi. And I have my Raspberry Pi on
我想已经有第四个版本了，还有几个变体。它们一直都是关于运行 Linux，几乎就像一台电脑，就像一台迷你电脑，对吧？它们有视频输出，有声音输出，它真的是一个非常复杂的单板系统，我想这是你会用的术语。是的，我的意思是，我买了一个 KVM。我的树莓派在
my desk. And I switched to it every now and then. And yeah, it's like a full desktop. Oh, KVM, KVM, KVM. Yeah, yeah, right. Yeah. So I mean, those Raspberry Pis have always been that. So to me, this is like a very surprise announcement that basically, they would be coming out with something more in the realm of what you traditionally have been talking about as an Arduino, which is a sort of microcontroller, they are putting an ARM core on their own silicon, which I guess maybe people don't know, but you hear about this ARM processor, that ARM processor. So ARM basically sells what you can think of, I guess, like as a program or an executable that runs on silicon or on an FPGA that executes computer instructions. And so you can buy that yourself, and then plug in various modules for what they call peripherals,
我的桌子上。我偶尔会切换到它。是的，它就像一个完整的桌面。哦，KVM，KVM，KVM。是的，是的，没错。所以我的意思是，那些树莓派一直都是那样的。所以对我来说，这是一个非常令人惊讶的公告，基本上，他们会推出一些更接近你传统上所说的 Arduino 的东西，这是一种微控制器，他们正在自己的芯片上放置一个 ARM 内核，我想也许人们不知道，但你听说过这个 ARM 处理器，那个 ARM 处理器。所以 ARM 基本上销售你可以认为是，我想，就像一个在硅片或 FPGA 上运行的程序或可执行文件，执行计算机指令。所以你可以自己购买，然后为他们所谓的“外设”插入各种模块，
like doing USB, doing PCIe, doing HDMI, you can buy other pieces of things that go into your, you know, either FPGA, or if you're going to make your own chip, your own silicon, they call an ASIC. And you can buy from ARM a license for one of these cores for running instructions. And you can put it on your own chip with whatever else you want and kind of make your own thing. And that's what Raspberry Pi has done and made these. And they put a couple cool peripherals for sort of in hardware implementing finite state machines that the first people are just now getting their hands on. And I'm very interested to see what will happen. But this space is kind of converging because before you had sort of Raspberry Pi for single board computers, Arduino for sort of microcontroller
比如做 USB，做 PCIe，做 HDMI，你可以购买其他进入你的，你知道，FPGA，或者如果你要制造自己的芯片，你自己的硅片，他们称之为 ASIC 的东西。你可以从 ARM 购买这些内核之一的许可证来运行指令。你可以把它放在你自己的芯片上，加上任何你想要的东西，做出你自己的东西。这就是树莓派所做的，并制造了这些。他们放了一些很酷的外设，用于在硬件中实现有限状态机，第一批人现在才刚刚拿到手。我非常感兴趣地想看看会发生什么。但这个领域正在趋同，因为之前你有用于单板计算机的树莓派，用于微控制器
oriented things. But now there's crossover. And I even saw a news article recently, where like Arduino is going to make a board that has the Raspberry Pi Pico on it. So Oh, nice. And it get very confusing for telling people what to use. But that's pretty cool. And Raspberry Pi and Arduino both have been a huge boon to people doing embedded development, not necessarily like for work or industrial purposes, but for hobbyists, especially, because the ability, which I need a formal name for the metric, but basically the ability to type into Google a question about what you're trying to solve
导向事物的 Arduino。但现在有了交叉。我甚至最近看到一篇新闻文章，Arduino 要制造一块带有树莓派 Pico 的板子。所以，哦，不错。这让告诉人们使用什么变得非常困惑。但这很酷。树莓派和 Arduino 对从事嵌入式开发的人来说都是巨大的福音，不一定是为工作或工业目的，而是对业余爱好者，特别是，因为这种能力——我需要一个正式的指标名称——但基本上是能够向 Google 输入一个关于你试图解决的问题的疑问，
and having real good answers come back has been very good with Raspberry Pi and Arduino, much better than anything ever before. So the amount of support, the adoption, the amount of users behind it. So if they can do the same thing with the Pico, it could be really transformative to the hobbyist microcontroller market.
并得到真正好的答案的能力，在树莓派和 Arduino 上非常好，比以往任何时候都好。所以支持量、采用率、背后的用户量。所以如果他们能用 Pico 做同样的事情，那对业余微控制器市场来说可能是革命性的。
Yeah, and the prices have been just absolutely astonishing. Like the Raspberry Pi was something like $30, maybe even $15 at one point. And the Pico is $4 for a microcontroller that has like, you know, a pretty good developer interface. Yeah, it's amazing. for for halloween we used uh an arduino to make a uh a little halloween thing that jumped out and and kind of scared people when they reached in to get candy and it was a blast i think uh it actually it really scared kids because especially at night you know because because it was made by hand which is you know plywood and some hobbywood you know no one was expecting it to move and And then when it moved, they didn't really know what was going to happen next because, you know, it obviously wasn't something you just got from home Depot.
是的，价格简直令人震惊。树莓派大约 30 美元，甚至一度 15 美元。而 Pico 是 4 美元，用于一个拥有相当不错的开发者界面的微控制器。是的，太棒了。万圣节时，我们用 Arduino 做了一个万圣节小装置，当人们伸手去拿糖果时，它会跳出来吓人，这太棒了。我想它真的吓到了孩子们，因为特别是在晚上，因为它是手工制作的，你知道，胶合板和一些爱好木材，没人预料到它会动。然后当它动的时候，他们真的不知道接下来会发生什么，因为，你知道，它显然不是你从家得宝买来的东西。
Right. So it just moved in this really awkward way and, uh, it, it legit scared, scared people in the neighborhood. So, and, and yeah, that was only possible through a lot of Googling, uh, buying things on Amazon and setting things on fire. Oh, wait, what? Yeah, the magic smoke. So yeah, this stuff's amazing. I'm glad it's reaching more people. My news is Kubernetes dropping Docker shim.
没错。所以它以这种非常尴尬的方式移动，而且，它确实吓到了邻居。所以，是的，这只有通过大量的 Google 搜索、在亚马逊上买东西和把东西烧掉才有可能实现。哦，等等，什么？是的，魔法烟雾。所以是的，这些东西太棒了。我很高兴它能触及更多人。我的新闻是 Kubernetes 放弃 Docker shim。
So this is a really, really interesting story. Most people are familiar with Docker. Actually, if we haven't done it, we should probably dedicate a whole show to Docker and containers. But just a high level, Docker is a way to kind of package up, let's say, installing an OS and then running a bunch of commands on it. So let's say, imagine you install Ubuntu on a machine and then you install MongoDB and you configure it. And let's say you need to do that many, many times. You could use what's called a Docker file to describe that process. And then you can create what's called a container, which is like a virtual operating system that sits on top of something called ContainerD or ContainerDaemon. And so the idea is you can kind of take these
这是一个非常非常有趣的故事。大多数人都熟悉 Docker。事实上，如果我们还没做过，我们可能应该专门做一期关于 Docker 和容器的节目。但从高层来看，Docker 是一种打包方式，比如安装一个操作系统，然后在上面运行一堆命令。所以，想象一下你在机器上安装 Ubuntu，然后安装 MongoDB 并配置它。假设你需要多次这样做。你可以使用所谓的 Dockerfile 来描述这个过程。然后你可以创建一个所谓的容器，它就像一个坐在所谓的 ContainerD 或 ContainerDaemon 之上的虚拟操作系统。所以这个想法是你可以把这些
modules and you can run them in the cloud, on your computer, you know, on a Raspberry Pi. And it's just kind of self-contained like that. So Docker really popularized this. I mean, there was, you know, chroot before, which did a decent job of this, as long as you're staying kind of in the Unix world. But Docker kind of, you know, brought it to everybody. You can run Docker on Mac, you can run Docker on Windows, you can have a Linux, you know, OS container running on Windows, and it just works. You can actually share folders. so you can you know have shared content between your actual os and the docker os and so on and so forth but the docker business story is not as like exciting or not as not as not as nice so you know docker started
模块拿走，在云端、在你的电脑上、在树莓派上运行它们。它就是这样自包含的。所以 Docker 真正普及了这一点。我的意思是，之前有 chroot，只要你待在 Unix 世界里，它做得还不错。但 Docker 把它带给了所有人。你可以在 Mac 上运行 Docker，可以在 Windows 上运行 Docker，你可以在 Windows 上运行 Linux 操作系统容器，它就是能工作。你实际上可以共享文件夹，所以你可以在你的实际操作系统和 Docker 操作系统之间共享内容，等等。但 Docker 的商业故事并不那么令人兴奋，或者说不那么好。所以 Docker 开始
getting into this thing which they call docker swarm, which was, you know, imagine you have a database and a web, you know, backend, and you have a load balancer, and they're all meant to work together, right? The load balancer points people to one of many web backends, and the web backends points to one of many of shards of this database, right? So all of those need to communicate to each other. And if they're all kind of containers, and especially if you're running in the public cloud where the cloud is turning them on and off or migrating them, it's not obvious how you're going to make all of that communication happen. And so Docker Swarm was a way to do that. It was, it was a service registry where you would
进入他们所谓的 Docker Swarm，也就是，想象一下你有一个数据库和一个 Web 后端，你有一个负载均衡器，它们都是为了协同工作，对吧？负载均衡器将人们指向多个 Web 后端之一，Web 后端指向该数据库的多个分片之一，对吧？所以所有这些都需要相互通信。如果它们都是容器，特别是如果你在公共云中运行，云在开启和关闭它们或迁移它们，如何实现所有这些通信并不明显。所以 Docker Swarm 就是一种实现方式。它是一个服务注册中心，你会
say like, Hey, I, you know, I'm, I'm a database container and the service registry registry would say, Oh, okay. Yeah. I've seen 10 of you before you're number 11. And then the website would say, Oh, I need to connect to the database. Um, you know, Docker, uh, swarm, tell me, you know, where, where my database is and it will, it,, you know, where my database is, and it will, it had a load balancer inside of it. And it would it would take care of all that for you. Right. So, you know, the interesting thing here is this, this new thing came out called Kubernetes. And it was almost equivalent. And I mean, I'm not an expert here. So I'm sure there's features that one has the other hasn't. But but in spirit, you know, it's the same as Docker swarm.. And it just had a way, way better developer experience. And it kind of just kind of eclipsed Docker.
说，嘿，我是一个数据库容器，服务注册中心会说，哦，好的。是的，我之前见过 10 个你，你是第 11 个。然后网站会说，哦，我需要连接到数据库。Docker Swarm，告诉我我的数据库在哪里，它会……它有一个内置的负载均衡器。它会为你处理所有这些。所以，这里有趣的是这个叫 Kubernetes 的新东西出来了。它几乎是等价的。我的意思是，我不是这方面的专家。所以我肯定有些功能一个有而另一个没有。但从精神上讲，它和 Docker Swarm 是一样的。而且它的开发者体验要好得多。它几乎掩盖了 Docker。
And this is really, you know, and so Docker shim was kind of like, you know, Kubernetes was kind of playing nice at a lot of parts of Docker. And Docker shim was a way to kind of make that all happen. And that's getting getting deprecated. So it's kind of the nail in the coffin for for Docker. Now, if you're if you're creating a Docker image, Docker container, that's actually using an open source format. So you can always use Docker to make containers and then run them on Kubernetes because it's a shared format. But, you know, Docker as, let's say, as a business, you know, really kind of got the legs pulled out from under them. And I just thought that was a little bit sad. little message of warning for, for people who, uh, who wants to start new things that you really
这真的是，Docker shim 就像是 Kubernetes 在 Docker 的很多部分表现得很好。而 Docker shim 是一种实现这一切的方式。现在它正在被弃用。所以这就像是 Docker 的棺材上的钉子。现在，如果你正在创建一个 Docker 镜像、Docker 容器，那实际上使用的是开源格式。所以你总是可以使用 Docker 来制作容器，然后在 Kubernetes 上运行它们，因为它是共享格式。但是，Docker 作为一家企业，真的被抽走了底座。我只是觉得这有点悲伤。给那些想开始新事物的人一点警告，你真的
have to have something that you can kind of charge for or something that's, that's kind of unique. Otherwise, uh, yeah, it's kind of a, kind of a tale of warning to folks out there. I feel that plays in a little bit, which we don't have here, but the elastic search thing as well with AWS, where AWS was running instances of Elasticsearch. And so people weren't using Elasticsearch's hosted service anymore. And so it's forced Elasticsearch into changing their license structure.
必须有你可以收费的东西，或者某种独特的东西。否则，这对于人们来说是一个警告故事。我觉得这有点像，虽然我们这里没有，但 AWS 的 Elasticsearch 事情也是如此，AWS 在运行 Elasticsearch 实例。所以人们不再使用 Elasticsearch 的托管服务了。所以这迫使 Elasticsearch 改变了他们的许可结构。
I mean, I think these things are just really hard. Like, it's really good that people want to do open source, and open source is awesome. But yeah, it's a fine balancing game. And it's really hard to know what's going to happen over the course of years. So just actually just to put a bookmark in this, this actually won't change anything. If you're someone who uses Docker on Kubernetes, unless you use the swarm parts of
我的意思是，我认为这些事情真的很难。人们想做开源真的很好，开源很棒。但这是一个微妙的平衡游戏。真的很难知道几年内会发生什么。所以只是为了在这里加个书签，这实际上不会改变任何事情。如果你是在 Kubernetes 上使用 Docker 的人，除非你使用 Docker 的 Swarm 部分，
Docker, like the load balancing, some of the really advanced stuff, or you have some really advanced node configuration that's specific to Docker, you know, most people probably don't even realize this, but but they're actually building these open standard containers that that aren't even really like a Docker specific thing anymore when they're done. And so this shouldn't actually affect 90% of people out there. But I just thought it was an interesting story. My next new story continues on stuff adjacent to open source, and that is GitHub one s. So there's a couple interesting angles from this. But basically, it turns out, I guess it was Microsoft added the ability to type one s to the end of GitHub for any GitHub repository and get a version of Visual Studio Code
比如负载均衡，一些非常高级的东西，或者你有特定于 Docker 的非常高级的节点配置，大多数人可能甚至没有意识到这一点，但他们实际上是在构建这些开放标准容器，当它们完成时，甚至不再真正像 Docker 特定的东西了。所以这实际上不应该影响 90% 的人。但我只是觉得这是一个有趣的故事。我的下一个新闻故事继续关于开源邻近的东西，那就是 GitHub 1s。这里有几个有趣的角度。但基本上，事实证明，我想是微软增加了在任何 GitHub 仓库的 GitHub 后面输入 1s 的能力，并在不到一秒钟的时间内获得一个 Visual Studio Code 版本，
open in your browser in under a second where you can browse the repository as if it was checked out locally with your version, like with VS Code pointed at it. And so you can browse using VS Code browser. You can look at the code that way and the styling and all of that in your web browser. That's two uses of the word
在你的浏览器中打开，你可以像在本地检出一样浏览仓库，就像 VS Code 指向它一样。所以你可以使用 VS Code 浏览器进行浏览。你可以通过这种方式查看代码，以及网页浏览器中的样式和所有这些。这是“浏览器”这个词的两次使用。
browser. I guess that's confusing. In your web browser, you can have the file browser of VS Code and the VS Code editor look for a random GitHub repo. If you went to github.com slash jetbrains slash kotlin, because that's what we're talking
我想这很令人困惑。在你的网页浏览器中，你可以拥有 VS Code 的文件浏览器，VS Code 编辑器可以查找任何随机的 GitHub 仓库。如果你去 github.com/jetbrains/kotlin，因为这就是我们今天讨论的
about today, and you would see normally the GitHub interface, you would see like at the top there, like GitHub, you know, file directory list. And then at the bottom, you would see like a rendering of the readme.md. Instead, if you did GitHub 1s dot com slash JetBrains slash Kotlin, you get an instance of VS Code, Microsoft's Visual Studio Code Editor, with the files on the left hand side and editing view of the readme.md on the right hand side. And so then you can just browse through it's just like a super cool use of like, the fact that Visual Studio Code is itself
关于 Kotlin 的内容，你通常会看到 GitHub 界面，你会看到顶部有 GitHub 文件目录列表。然后在底部，你会看到 readme.md 的渲染。相反，如果你输入 github1s.com/jetbrains/kotlin，你会得到一个 VS Code 实例，微软的 Visual Studio Code 编辑器，左侧有文件，右侧有 readme.md 的编辑视图。所以你可以浏览，这只是一个超级酷的利用，利用了 Visual Studio Code 本身就是
JavaScript to come run in your browser. And that GitHub has the APIs that you can hook into and call this way. It also points out how horrible GitHub's file browsing was and how awesome it is to be able to do this. Like it's so much easier to browse random repos this way. Yeah, do you know if you can edit a file and create a pull request? I saw some stuff about it, but I didn't look into it because that's not sort of the normal thing I kind of do. But I did see that there were some people commenting about doing that workflow. So I think there is a workflow there, but I don't know what it is. And the other thing is, I feel I feel like it's only a matter of time. So apparently,
JavaScript，可以在你的浏览器中运行。而且 GitHub 有你可以挂钩并以这种方式调用的 API。这也指出了 GitHub 的文件浏览是多么糟糕，以及能够做到这一点是多么棒。浏览随机仓库要容易得多。是的，你知道你可以编辑文件并创建拉取请求吗？我看到了一些关于它的东西，但我没有深入研究，因为那不是我通常做的事情。但我确实看到有人评论说要进行那种工作流程。所以我认为那里有一个工作流程，但我不知道它是什么。另一件事是，我觉得这只是时间问题。所以显然，
there's also an internal thing in GitHub that's starting to roll out called workspaces. That's for doing this kind of thing, like basically doing all your editing in the browser, in the web browser, but it's not fully rolled out yet. And then also, like, doing all your editing in the browser, in the web browser, but it's not fully rolled out yet. And then also, like, unfortunately, this doesn't work for like internal enterprise instances of GitHub. But one of the things that I found interesting is there's a disclaimer at the bottom, if you do this, go github1s.com slash some repository that says this is not an officially supported thing. But then I realized, wait a second, like, maybe it's not
GitHub 内部还有一个东西开始推出，叫 Workspaces。那是为了做这种事情，基本上在浏览器中完成你所有的编辑，在网页浏览器中，但它还没有完全推出。而且，不幸的是，这不适用于 GitHub 的内部企业实例。但我发现有趣的一件事是，底部有一个免责声明，如果你这样做，去 github1s.com/某个仓库，它说这不是官方支持的东西。但我意识到，等一下，也许它不是
from microsoft but visual studio code is a microsoft product microsoft bought github like i'm not clear uh what makes it an authorized thing unless it's not being done by microsoft so oh yeah that was my that was my impression was that someone just some did this as a hobby and oh maybe it is maybe it's not being done by microsoft then but it is kind of a cool use of the various technologies and smooshing them together in an interesting way and really does point out that like oh it is some random person and it's not microsoft okay that does explain it yeah it's still awesome super cool like why we didn't do this before why this wasn't like a thing i have no idea but like for now on like anytime you end up on a you know random public github repo like just add that one s and enjoy being able to uh
来自微软，但 Visual Studio Code 是微软产品，微软买了 GitHub，我不清楚是什么让它成为授权的东西，除非它不是由微软完成的，所以哦，是的，我的印象是有人只是把它当作爱好，哦，也许是，也许不是由微软完成的，但它确实是各种技术的酷利用，以有趣的方式将它们揉在一起，确实指出了，哦，它是一个随机的人，不是微软，好的，这确实解释了它。是的，它仍然很棒，超级酷，为什么我们以前没这样做，为什么这不是一个东西，我不知道，但从现在开始，任何时候你最终在一个随机的公共 GitHub 仓库上，只需加上那个 1s，享受能够
browse it much more conveniently yeah this is amazing yeah i'm gonna use this yeah definitely every day i mean this is something that we do all the time is look at open source implementations of different stuff and this And this is so cool. Cool. All right. My next show topic is algorithms for decision making, which is a free book that you can download. And a lot of people don't know a lot about decision making. decision-making. So when they think about machine learning, they think about classifying dogs and cats and the house example, like figuring out the price of a house and a lot of these supervised
更方便地浏览它。是的，这太棒了。是的，我会用这个。是的，绝对每天都用。我的意思是，这是我们一直在做的事情，查看不同东西的开源实现。这太酷了。酷。好的。我的下一个节目话题是决策算法，这是一本你可以下载的免费书。很多人对决策了解不多。决策。所以当他们想到机器学习时，他们想到的是分类猫狗，还有房子例子，比如计算房子的价格，以及很多这些监督
learning things, which are awesome. They're definitely really powerful. But a lot of people don't have exposure to decision-making. And so they might think, well, if I use supervised learning to predict all the outcomes of a decision, and then I can just have a for loop or something and pick the best one. And the problem is that doesn't actually work because the algorithms that you're using to forecast are themselves, you know, the data that's driving those forecasts came from some other decision making system. So and so there's there's error and there's bias in those. Like, for example, you know, on YouTube, it could be that the if you search for a certain query, like you search for, let's say, funny, you know, the top 10 videos that come up, people will be more likely to click on those than the 11th video, which is, you know, you have to click on next
学习的东西，它们很棒。它们确实非常强大。但很多人没有接触过决策。所以他们可能会想，好吧，如果我使用监督学习来预测决策的所有结果，然后我就可以用一个 for 循环或类似的东西来选择最好的一个。问题是这实际上行不通，因为你用来预测的算法本身，你知道，驱动这些预测的数据来自其他决策系统。所以，这里面有错误和偏差。例如，你知道，在 YouTube 上，可能是如果你搜索某个查询，比如你搜索，让我们说，有趣的，出来的排名前 10 的视频，人们点击这些视频的可能性比第 11 个视频要大，也就是，你必须点击下一页才能到达。所以，一个天真的系统可能会说，好吧，那 10 个视频比第 11 个视频更有趣，对吧？但它没有考虑到 UI 引起的这种偏差，对吧？所以，这是，你知道，那是一个例子，但还有许多其他例子，决策确实就像它自己的领域。我真的认为这本书在覆盖不同领域方面做得很好。而且，你知道，深入细节，谈论一点理论，比如，哦，如果你有这个非常简单的例子，有两个变量和一个决策，那么你如何完全解决它？然后进入更实际的
page to get to. And so, and so a naive system might say, well, those 10 videos are just funnier than the 11th video, right? But it's, it's not taking into account that sort of bias that was induced by the UI, right? So, and that's, you know, that's, that's, you know, kind of one example, but there's many other examples where decision making is really kind of like its own field. And I really thought this book did a good job of, you know, covering the different areas. And, you know, kind of going into detail talking a little bit about kind of theoretical, like, oh, if you have this really simple example where there's two variables and a decision, then how can you sort of completely solve that? And then getting into like the more practical
例子以及你必须做的所有近似和所有事情。但是的，我觉得这写得很好，一定要看看，让我们知道你的想法。所以我必须决定是否要买这个？是的，没错。是的，所以你应该做 Epsilon Greedy。你应该掷硬币。
examples and all the sort of approximations and all the things that you have to do there. But yeah, I thought this was really well written and definitely check it out and let us know what you think. So I have to make a decision about whether or not to get this? Yeah, that's right. Yeah, so you should do Epsilon Greedy. You should flip a coin.
如果是正面，你应该读整本书。如果是反面，你也应该读整本书。好吧，它的发布日期是 2022 年。那个家伙，作者的名字之一是 Wheeler，所以我喜欢这个，我喜欢这个。好的，这是一个好的开始。我必须承认我有点偏见，我的意思是这是我的领域，但我认为这是一本做得很好的书。节目之书的时间到了。节目之书。节目之书。我的节目之书是《反脆弱》。《反脆弱》是一本书，我实际上忘了作者的名字。
And if it's heads, you should read the entire book. And if it's tails, you should still read the entire book. Well, it has a release date of 2022. And the guy, one of the author's names is Wheeler so i like this i'm into this all right it's it's a good start i have to admit i'm a little bit biased i mean this is my area but uh um but i i thought it was a really well done book time for book of the show book of the show. Book of the show. My book of the show is Anti-Fragile. Anti-Fragile is a book, and I actually forgot the author's name.
我得查一下。Nassim Taleb。Nassim Taleb，谢谢。反脆弱是一个非常有趣的假设。我必须承认，我没有读完整本书。这本书实际上是三本书合一。在开头，在序言中，Nassim 谈到了它是三本书，出版商想让他出三本书，他只出了一本，等等。但这是一本非常非常
I'll have to look that up. Nassim Tlaib. Nassim Tlaib, thank you. And Anti-Fragile is a really interesting premise. I have to admit, I didn't read the entire book. The book is actually, it's three books in one. And in the beginning, in the preamble, Nassim talks about how it's three books and the publisher wanted him to release three books and he just released one and so on and so forth. But it's a very, very,
长的书。有很多非常棒的内容。但前提，至少表面上是，人们认为脆弱的东西就像玻璃杯。如果你有一盒玻璃杯，你会写上“易碎”。你会希望运送你玻璃杯的人会对此格外小心。其他东西是稳健的。所以如果你运送砖块，你只会有一托盘砖块。你不会在上面写“易碎”。但如果操作叉车的人对砖块非常粗鲁，它们会破碎，然后你就会有损失。那些砖块，你必须把它们扔掉，对吧？
very long book. There's a lot of really great content. But the premise, at least ostensibly, is that people think of fragile things like a glass cup. If you had a box full of glass cups, you'd write fragile on it. And you would hope that the person shipping your glass cups would take some extra care with that. And other things are robust. So if you are shipping bricks, you would just have a pallet of bricks. You wouldn't write fragile on them. But if the person operating the forklift was super rough with the bricks, they would shatter and then you would have loss. And those bricks, you'd have to just throw them away, right?
那是稳健的，对吧？但他提出了反脆弱，这实际上意味着，你知道，你每打碎一块砖，你知道，又会形成另外两块砖，诸如此类，对吧？所以，你知道，对于那个，你知道，隐喻并没有向那个方向延伸。但想想你的手臂，例如，如果你骨折了，你知道，通常，只要它被正确夹板固定，一切，你的臂骨实际上会愈合并变得更强，你知道，通常，只要它被正确夹板固定，一切，你的臂骨实际上会愈合并变得更强，你知道，或者甚至，甚至一个更简单的例子是如果你只是举重，或者如果你打沙袋之类的，你知道，如果你打沙袋，你指关节里的钙实际上会变得更致密。如果你举重，你知道，你的肌肉会变得更强，等等。
That's robust, right? But he proposes anti-fragile, which actually means that, you know, for every brick you break, like, you know, another two bricks are formed or something like that, right? And so, you know, for that, you know, the metaphor doesn't extend in that direction. But think about your arm, for example, if you break your arm, you know, typically, as long as it's, you know, splinted correctly and everything, your arm bone will actually heal and develop stronger, you know, typically as long as it's, you know, splinted correctly and everything, your arm bone will actually heal and develop stronger, you know, or even, even a simpler example is if you just, if you lift weights or if you punch a punching bag or something like that, uh, you know, the, if you punch a punching bag, the calcium in your knuckles will actually become more dense. If you lift weights, you know, your muscles will become stronger, so on and so forth.
所以这些东西在受伤时实际上会变得更好。所以他把这个概念应用到金融领域和一大堆其他领域，并应用到经营企业上。反脆弱这本书中还交织着黑天鹅的概念，这是一种罕见但灾难性的事件。他的核心论点之一是，如果你以某种方式发展你的企业，或者如果你以某种方式发展经济，你最终会得到很多小的破碎。所以他使用的一个好例子是餐饮业，那里不断有夫妻店开业、倒闭、停业，新的店形成。所以存在持续的脆弱性。
And so these are things where as they're sort of injured, they actually become better. And so he takes that concept and applies it to the financial arena and a whole bunch of other areas and applies it to running a business. You also woven into this anti-fragile book is this concept of black swans, which are kind of rare but catastrophic events. And one of his core thesis is that if you develop your business in a certain way or if you develop an economy in a certain way, you'll end up with a lot of small breaks. So a good example that he used is the restaurant industry where there's constantly mom and pop restaurants starting up and shutting down and going out of business and new ones forming. And so there's constant fragility
因此，这些事物在受损时反而会变得更好。他将这一概念应用到了金融领域、许多其他领域以及企业经营中。在这本《反脆弱》书中，他还融入了“黑天鹅”的概念，即那些罕见但具有灾难性的事件。他的核心论点之一是，如果你以某种方式发展企业或经济，最终会导致许多小规模的崩溃。他举的一个很好的例子是餐饮业，那里不断有夫妻店开业、倒闭、破产，又有新的店面成立。因此，这里存在着持续的脆弱性。
at an individual restaurant level, but all of that life and death allows the overall restaurant industry to be very fragile. And he goes into, you know, wine, how that is. But yeah, I think the book is really interesting. It's, as I said, a lot of content. I think even if you just read the first book, you would get a lot out of it. And it's priced as one book. So it's very reasonable. So for, I guess I've actually heard nassim talk about the anti-fragile book in person during a talk he was giving when he first released it but for the
在个体餐厅层面，但所有这些生与死使得整个餐饮业变得非常脆弱。他深入探讨了葡萄酒等领域的情况。不过，是的，我认为这本书非常有趣。正如我所说，内容非常丰富。我想即使你只读第一本书，也能获益良多。而且它按一本书的价格出售，所以非常合理。所以，我想我确实在纳西姆（Nassim）刚发布《反脆弱》（Antifragile）这本书时，亲自听过他的一次演讲，但对于……
if you really want something kind of interesting so nassim's background is um he was a derivatives or is a derivatives trader so he he works in the finance industry doing options trading and stuff i believe and yeah that's right so part of his thesis, whatever, anyway, part of what he's driving at in these books is like, how would you orient yourself if you were going to buy options or something or futures? And how would you think about black swan events or having a portfolio which is anti-fragile? But if you kind of want like a trip down, whoa, this is kind of fascinating and hilarious between two sort of high profile figures. Nassim is somewhat, I guess, Internet famous for getting into it with Nate Silver, who we've talked about before.
如果你真的想要一些有趣的东西，纳西姆的背景是……嗯，他曾是一名衍生品交易员，或者现在也是，所以他相信他在金融行业从事期权交易之类的工作。是的，没错。所以他的部分论点，无论如何，他在这些书中想要表达的部分内容是：如果你打算购买期权或期货之类的东西，你会如何定位自己？你会如何思考“黑天鹅”事件，或者拥有一个“反脆弱”的投资组合？但如果你想了解两位知名人物之间那种“哇，这太迷人又太搞笑了”的经历，纳西姆因为与内特·西尔弗（Nate Silver）发生争执而在互联网上小有名气，我们之前也谈到过他。
Oh, I didn't even know this. The guy of FiveThirtyEight. So he was the one who became famous, Nate Silver was, for predicting a lot of the congressional and presidential races. What would that have been two or three times ago. And so 538 is a number of electoral votes that we have for president. So he runs this blog 538, he's become pretty famous about this. And he writes books and stuff as well. But they both talk somewhat about, I guess, like you would say, predictions and modeling and how to talk about probabilities. And Nate Silver's book, The Signal and the Noise or Signal from the Noise.
哦，我甚至不知道这一点。就是FiveThirtyEight网站的那个人。所以他成名是因为内特·西尔弗预测了许多国会和总统选举。那大概是两三次选举前的事了。538是我们总统选举人团的票数。所以他经营着这个名为538的博客，并因此变得相当出名。他也写书之类的。但他们两人都谈论了一些，我想你会说是预测、建模以及如何谈论概率的问题。内特·西尔弗的书叫《信号与噪声》（The Signal and the Noise）。
I don't remember what it's called. Anyway, so they get into it. I think it's The Signal from the Noise. Okay. So they get into it on Twitter, specifically before the last presidential election, about what was the right way to kind of think about or to kind of decide how likely it was that President Trump would be reelected or that President Biden, I guess not spoiler alert, but or whether Biden would be elected. And so it's kind of funny, because Nassim sort of, I don't understand most
我不记得它叫什么了。总之，他们为此争论起来。我想是《信号与噪声》。好吧。所以他们在推特上为此争论，特别是在上次总统大选之前，关于思考或决定特朗普总统连任或拜登总统当选（我想这不是剧透，或者说拜登是否会当选）的可能性，什么是正确的方法。所以这很有趣，因为纳西姆有点……我不明白大部分
of the nuance. But his sort of take was like, oh, we should have a betting market, a predictions market, and people could place real money. And then you could be able to see the true weight of it versus that's very different than how Nate Silver does his modeling and taking a lot of survey data and compositing them into a model and trying to understand like what people's preferences are being likely outcomes. And so they get into it about whether or not which one of them has the right approach. And they seem to really not like each other is my takeaway. Wow. Yeah, I had no idea. I don't I don't follow him on on on social media. So I didn't know that that's, is he at least polite about it? Like, is this I can't, you know, it's hard sometimes on Twitter, like, to tell if people are being like pop shoddy as like an affectation or like whether they're really like frustrated. So yeah, it makes sense.
细微差别。但他的观点是，哦，我们应该有一个博彩市场，一个预测市场，人们可以投入真金白银。然后你就能看到它的真实权重，这与内特·西尔弗进行建模的方式非常不同，内特是获取大量调查数据并将它们组合成一个模型，试图了解人们的偏好是什么，从而得出可能的结论。所以他们就他们俩谁的方法正确而争论不休。我的结论是他们似乎真的很讨厌对方。哇。是的，我完全不知道。我不关注他的社交媒体。所以我不知道那是……他至少对此有礼貌吗？就像，我无法……你知道，在推特上有时很难判断人们是在装腔作势，还是真的感到沮丧。所以，是的，这说得通。
Anyways, check it out if you're into that kind of thing. Some other people I know who are more, have a background in statistics and are, I guess, style themselves as statisticians find this hilarious and they're very into it and they get into arguments about it, but it all goes over my head. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, maybe the, the following, like the second and the third book get, get really technical. I think there's something really appealing about, I think the premise and yeah, I don't know, you know, I would love to see, yeah, maybe we'll see. I'll dig up if Nate Silver has sort of real, like a counter argument to this anti-fragile sort of, you know, like ecosystem that Nassim has set up here. But yeah, I think either way,
总之，如果你对这类事情感兴趣，可以去看看。我认识的其他一些更有统计学背景、自诩为统计学家的人觉得这很有趣，他们非常沉迷于此，并为此争论不休，但这超出了我的理解范围。是的。是的。我的意思是，也许第二本和第三本会变得非常专业。我认为前提本身非常有吸引力，是的，我不知道，你知道，我很想看到……也许我们会看到的。我会去查查内特·西尔弗是否对纳西姆在这里建立的这种“反脆弱”生态系统有真正的反驳意见。但无论如何，
it's really good to see sort of this point of view. I thought that was really interesting. I feel like Black Swan and anti-fragile have been like somewhat, well, I guess Nate Silver's approach to it, but leaving that aside. Anyways, Nassim has been one of those things where he came out with these ideas and then everyone latched onto them and realized they were really good abstractions. And so you hear it a lot in certain areas.
能看到这种观点真的很好。我觉得这很有趣。我觉得《黑天鹅》和《反脆弱》已经变得有点……好吧，我想是内特·西尔弗的方法，但撇开那个不谈。总之，纳西姆就是那种提出了这些想法，然后每个人都抓住它们并意识到它们是非常好的抽象概念的人。所以你在某些领域经常听到这些。
Yeah, yeah, totally. My book of the show is less educational, I guess. Very much less educational. So this is a fantasy book. This is the shadow of what was lost by James Islington. It's actually the first of three books, which are all out now. So and finishes the trilogy, I guess. So you can be content knowing that it will be finished, unlike some other authors. And this book is about a world where I guess there's like a couple different kinds of what you want to call like magic.
是的，是的，完全同意。我的本期推荐书目没那么有教育意义，我想。非常缺乏教育意义。这是一本奇幻小说。这是詹姆斯·伊斯林顿（James Islington）的《被遗忘的阴影》（The Shadow of What Was Lost）。实际上这是三部曲中的第一部，现在都已经出版了。所以，它完成了三部曲，我想。所以你可以放心，它会完结，不像其他一些作者。这本书讲述了一个世界，我想那里有几种你称之为“魔法”的东西。
And one magic has been kind of deemed as forbidden and is like kind of punished. And the other magic is sort of like tolerated, but trying to be like constrained. And, you know, kind of a lot has happened in the past. And there's a little bit of time travel that takes place. And I just thought it was really well done. It's like super fun read. I was very interested to hear what happened. I thought it was really good.
其中一种魔法被视为禁忌并受到某种惩罚。而另一种魔法则被容忍，但试图受到限制。而且，你知道，过去发生了很多事情。其中还有一点时间旅行。我只是觉得它写得非常好。这是一本超级有趣的读物。我非常有兴趣听到后来发生了什么。我觉得它真的很棒。
And then I realized you should never read reviews about books because I went to go read the reviews about the book after I read it because I didn't want it to be spoiled. And people were hating on it. So I guess books are a little bit of preference. The people were complaining about stuff that I thought was legitimate. But it turns out mostly I feel feel it was like, kind of pedantic, like, oh, the characters didn't have strong character development throughout the book, they stayed mostly the same. And it's like, oh,
然后我意识到你不应该读关于书的评论，因为我在读完这本书后去看了评论，因为我不想被剧透。人们都在抨击它。所以我想书有点个人喜好问题。人们抱怨的事情我觉得是合理的。但事实证明，大部分我觉得是有点迂腐，比如，“书中的角色没有很强的人物成长，他们基本保持不变。”就像，哦，
I didn't even pay attention to that. I guess I treat books when I read them a lot, like just TV shows or movies or whatever, I watch them and I enjoy them. And then I kind of move on, I don't find myself thinking deeply about fiction books. Yeah, I think that is the challenge is it just in general, people who write reviews are much more technical on really any topic. I mean, same thing with video games. I was looking up a good game for, you know, my older my son to play. And yeah, when you read the reviews, it gets super technical. And it actually wasn't that useful so anyways i really like the book i would give it a recommendation not like my oh this is the best book ever but like this is really good if you're looking for something to read has a fair amount of heft to it it's a trilogy that's done and it's a it's a good world i would i would
我甚至没注意到这一点。我想我读小说时，就像看电视节目或电影一样，我看了，我很享受。然后我就继续看别的了，我不会深入思考虚构类书籍。是的，我认为这就是挑战，通常写评论的人在任何话题上都更专业。我的意思是，电子游戏也是一样。我正在为我大儿子找一款好游戏。是的，当你读评论时，它们变得超级专业。实际上并没有什么用，所以无论如何，我真的很喜欢这本书，我会推荐它，不是那种“这是有史以来最好的书”，而是“如果你正在寻找读物，这本书真的很不错，它有一定的分量，这是一个已经完结的三部曲，而且是一个很好的世界”，我会……
recommend shadow of what was lost by james islington cool so how do you read you know given that you don't have a commute at least, given that you don't have a commute, at least I'm assuming you don't have a commute. Like what is, what is the right time for you? Is it, is it when you're going to sleep or, or what do you usually read?
推荐詹姆斯·伊斯林顿的《被遗忘的阴影》。酷。那么你是怎么阅读的呢？考虑到你没有通勤，至少，考虑到你没有通勤，至少我假设你没有通勤。那么，对你来说合适的时间是什么时候？是在你要睡觉的时候，还是你通常什么时候阅读？
It's a great question. I haven't sort of like fixed my post COVID getting books. Like I used to listen to them all on, on audible plug. Um, but, but just before they even were a sponsor, like we, I just, that's how I always have done. Yeah. And so this one actually finished most of
这是一个很好的问题。我还没有固定好疫情后的阅读习惯。我过去常在Audible上听书，插播一下。嗯，但在他们成为赞助商之前，我们就……我一直都是这么做的。是的。所以这一本实际上大部分是在……
like before COVID, but we've not had a lot of, uh, what could the show is since then. So, um, now I find myself actually struggling. Like it's, I don't think I read as much as I want to, uh, in part because I don't have the commute. And so I haven't found a good replacement strategy yet. Yeah, I'm in the same boat. What I've started doing is trying to read at night, but I just fall asleep. And so I found the sleep timer in Audible to be really useful. But even then, it's like at most, that makes it so I don't end up at the end of the book when I wake up, but I still have to figure out, okay, how much of that 30 minutes did I actually listen to? Yeah. Yeah. Um, I think actually, well, yeah, I think paper books might be better now that I spend much
疫情前读完的，但从那以后我们没有太多……节目内容。所以，嗯，现在我发现自己实际上很挣扎。就像，我不认为我读得像我想读的那么多，部分原因是我没有通勤。所以我还没有找到一个好的替代策略。是的，我也一样。我开始尝试在晚上阅读，但我总是睡着了。所以我发现Audible里的睡眠定时器非常有用。但即便如此，它最多也就是让我醒来时不会读到书的结尾，但我仍然得弄清楚，好吧，那30分钟里我到底听了多少？是的。是的。嗯，我想实际上，嗯，是的，我想纸质书现在可能更好，因为我花了很多
more time at my house, but I just got now the habit of buying paper books because I would never read them. So I don't know, maybe I need to try buying some book and paperback or hardback and trying it. Yeah, it's a really good, really good point. I, yeah, I have found the the audible, like or the audio book at night thing to work relatively well. Or maybe kind of early in the morning type thing. But But yeah, I definitely you know, I think once things kind of open back up, then you know, it'll definitely be the book, the audio book reading will pick back up. So, I mean, if you still have a time or are interested in hearing it. Yeah. With that, with that glowing endorsement. Audible is a, is a sponsor of the show and you can go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown and you can get a trial thing get a book check it out see if
更多时间在家里，但我现在养成了买纸质书的习惯，因为我从来不读它们。所以我不知道，也许我需要尝试买一些平装书或精装书来试试。是的，这是一个非常好的观点。我，是的，我发现晚上听Audible或有声读物效果还不错。或者也许是清晨之类的。但是，是的，我肯定，你知道，我认为一旦事情恢复正常，那么，你知道，有声读物阅读肯定会恢复。所以，我的意思是，如果你还有时间或者有兴趣听的话。是的。带着那样的热烈推荐。Audible是本节目的赞助商，你可以去audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以获得一个试用，拿一本书，看看它是否
it works for you i mean there are still plenty of times to do it if you if you have a yard and do yard work if you like folding laundry um walking the dog going for your you know jog i need to be doing that um those kinds of things i mean i think those are great times to uh listen to books on audio and actually encourage yourself to maybe do it a little longer than you might otherwise, because you get really into a good book. Yeah, yeah, totally. Actually, you know, before winter, when I was mowing the lawn, that actually was probably, you know, during the pandemic, that was the majority of my audible time, I would say would be, would be doing yard work. And then ask, why are you out there mowing every other day? Yeah, yeah, exactly. I'm like, shh, don't tell the family.
适合你。我的意思是，如果你有院子并做庭院工作，如果你喜欢折叠衣服，遛狗，去慢跑，我需要做那些，那些时间里有很多机会可以听书。我的意思是，我认为那些是听有声读物的绝佳时间，实际上鼓励你自己可能比平时多听一会儿，因为你真的沉浸在一本好书中。是的，是的，完全同意。实际上，你知道，在冬天之前，当我割草时，那实际上可能，你知道，在疫情期间，那是我大部分Audible时间，我会说是在做庭院工作。然后问，你为什么每隔一天就在外面割草？是的，是的，完全正确。我说，嘘，别告诉家人。
Grass grows really fast. Yeah. Yeah. Also, you can support us on Patreon, patreon.com slash programming throwdown. We definitely appreciate everyone's support. We're going to look into getting a Sven intern to join and we're hoping we can use the funds that y'all have contributed to ultimately
草长得真的很快。是的。是的。此外，你可以在Patreon上支持我们，patreon.com/programmingthrowdown。我们绝对感谢大家的支持。我们打算找一个Sven实习生加入，我们希望我们可以利用你们贡献的资金最终
produce more content. I think we've used it in the past to advertise the show, and that's been really successful. And we've been able to teach this whole area and describe what it's like to work in tech to so many more people. And now we're going to pivot a little bit away from ads and the direct outreach and more towards producing more content and in a way that's productive and efficient for us. So we really appreciate all of your support. Yes. Thank you to all of our patrons. Yeah. And with that, it is tool of the show. My this show is sentry sentry is a it's it's a bunch of tools but you could access it from their website i think it's sentry.com but it is
制作更多内容。我想我们过去曾用它来宣传节目，而且非常成功。我们已经能够教导整个领域，并向更多人描述在科技行业工作是什么样的。现在我们将稍微从广告和直接推广转向制作更多内容，并以一种对我们来说高效且富有成效的方式。所以我们非常感谢你们所有的支持。是的。感谢我们所有的赞助人。是的。说到这里，是本期工具推荐。我的工具是Sentry。Sentry是一堆工具，但你可以从他们的网站访问它，我想是sentry.com，但它是一个
a way to collect errors and crashes and um i recently integrated um eternal terminal in with integrated Eternal Terminal with Sentry and found it to be really, really useful. So a quick recap, Eternal Terminal, it's this SSH-like program. And it's been getting really, really popular, which is super, super fun. But it also means that there's all sorts of esoteric errors. And there's all sorts of other crashes I don't even know about that are happening. And so I wanted to find a way to collect crashes and these other things. And I tried a bunch of different alternatives. At a low level, there are some pretty standard things. There's like Breakpad and Crashpad. And on Mac, there's Crash Reporter, right? But I really wanted something that was higher level where I wasn't going to have to write so many bits and pieces.
收集错误和崩溃的方法，我最近将Eternal Terminal与Sentry集成在一起，发现它真的非常有用。快速回顾一下，Eternal Terminal，它是一个类似SSH的程序。它变得非常非常受欢迎，这超级超级有趣。但也意味着有各种各样的深奥错误。还有各种我甚至不知道的其他崩溃正在发生。所以我想要找到一种收集崩溃和这些其他东西的方法。我尝试了一堆不同的替代方案。在底层，有一些相当标准的东西。有像Breakpad和Crashpad。在Mac上，有Crash Reporter，对吧？但我真的想要一些更高级的东西，我不需要写那么多零碎的代码。
And after trying a few things, Sentry was by far the best. The way it works is, you know, in this case, it's a native C++ app. So I was using the Sentry native library. But you link this Sentry native library into your code. They have a relatively simple API. In my case, when Eternal Terminal starts, it looks for a config file. If it doesn't see it, it creates it and it puts a little UUID in there, a unique identifier.
在尝试了几种东西之后，Sentry是目前为止最好的。它的工作方式是，你知道，在这种情况下，它是一个原生的C++应用程序。所以我使用了Sentry原生库。但你将这个Sentry原生库链接到你的代码中。他们有一个相对简单的API。在我的例子中，当Eternal Terminal启动时，它会寻找一个配置文件。如果它没看到，它会创建它，并在里面放一个小的UUID，一个唯一标识符。
And then it'll use that identifier to dedupe. So if you crash, you know, a hundred times, it won't generate, you know, a hundred different reports on the backend. And then there was, you know, just some hooks into like the signaling system for Unix and Windows and all of that. So when there's any type of crash or anything, it just ships the log off. But yeah, it works great. So there's a Sentry dashboard and I can see in the past 24 hours, all the crash messages, and then I can go back in the code and try and decipher what
然后它会使用该标识符进行去重。所以如果你崩溃了一百次，它不会在后端生成一百个不同的报告。然后还有一些针对Unix和Windows等的信号系统的钩子。所以当有任何类型的崩溃或任何事情时，它只是发送日志。但是的，它工作得很好。所以有一个Sentry仪表板，我可以看到过去24小时内所有的崩溃信息，然后我可以回到代码中尝试破译发生了什么
happened and it gives stack traces and everything. So yeah, I thought it was a pretty cool system and I recommend it. I haven't actually paid for anything yet, but this is in master, internal terminal master. I haven't done it in a release yet. And even on master, I'm hitting the 5,000 event limit. So I'll probably switch to the paid version before I actually cut a new release. And I've been happy enough with it that it's already provided really good value for me. Nice. It looks like it's sentry.io. Oh yeah, cool. Thanks for the correction.
它提供了堆栈跟踪和一切。所以是的，我认为这是一个非常酷的系统，我推荐它。我实际上还没有付过任何钱，但这在master分支，Eternal Terminal master中。我还没有在发布版本中做过。即使在master上，我也达到了5000个事件的限制。所以我可能会在真正发布新版本之前切换到付费版本。而且我对它非常满意，它已经为我提供了非常好的价值。不错。看起来是sentry.io。哦，是的，酷。谢谢你的纠正。
And Sentry like monitoring, not Sentry like 100 years. Oh, yeah, yeah, Sentry. But yeah, check it out in the show notes. We'll put a link to it that's accurate and everything. It's really cool. And also, I think they do like browser and stuff. I mean, I wasn't building a website,
是Sentry监控，不是Sentry像100年那样。哦，是的，是的，Sentry。但是的，在节目笔记中查看它。我们会放一个准确的链接和一切。它真的很酷。而且，我想他们也做浏览器之类的。我的意思是，我不是在构建网站，
so I don't know for sure. But yeah, I mean, they also support a ton of other languages. So if you're doing Python or Node.js or whatever, they have bindings for all of that. My tool of the show is, for once, not a game, an actual tool that is Ninja, which is ninja-build.org. Ninja is, I guess you would is just like a replacement for make. Yeah. So if you are building C++ or C projects, you're very familiar with make, make itself invokes the compiler, but it is itself monitors dependencies and determines what and when things need to be rebuilt. But make makes is quite legacy at this this point i guess you would say like it's been
所以我不能确定。但是的，我的意思是，他们也支持大量的其他语言。所以如果你在做Python或Node.js或任何东西，他们都有所有这些的绑定。我的本期工具推荐，破天荒不是游戏，是一个真正的工具，那就是Ninja，即ninja-build.org。Ninja是，我想你会说它只是make的替代品。是的。所以如果你在构建C++或C项目，你非常熟悉make，make本身调用编译器，但它本身监控依赖关系并确定什么以及何时需要重新构建。但make在这一点上相当老旧，我想你会说，就像它已经
around for a long time still works and a lot of people you know kind of are very into it but it's not always in my opinion the fastest or the best yep at figuring out when and what needs to be rebuilt so it often over builds things or is slow to figure it out especially on bigger projects which i happen to be be working on present. And so Ninja was suggested and I tried it and it handles things like understanding you have multi-cores. And so doing in Make, it would be the dash J option for running multiple jobs in parallel.
存在很长时间了，仍然有效，很多人，你知道，有点非常喜欢它，但在我看来，它并不总是最快或最好的，在弄清楚何时以及什么需要重新构建方面。是的，所以它经常过度构建东西，或者在弄清楚它时很慢，特别是在我目前正在处理的大型项目上。所以有人建议使用Ninja，我试了一下，它处理诸如理解你有多个核心之类的事情。所以在Make中，它将是用于并行运行多个作业的-J选项。
It's really quick at figuring out the dependency graph and what needs to be built. So if you're building everything, I don't think you would see much difference between Make and Ninja to be honest, but maybe. But if you're doing partial builds, ninjas definitely noticeably faster and pretty easy and best of all I don't actually never written a ninja config file what happens is since I use cmake on on my project we normally would use cmake which outputs make files for you so that's kind of
它在弄清楚依赖图和需要构建的内容方面非常快。所以如果你在构建所有东西，老实说，我不认为你会看到Make和Ninja之间有太大区别，但也许吧。但如果你在做部分构建，Ninja绝对明显更快，而且非常简单，最棒的是我实际上从来没有写过Ninja配置文件，发生的情况是，因为我在我的项目上使用cmake，我们通常会使用cmake，它为你输出make文件，所以这有点
confusing to me anyways but you have a cmake. CMake makes the Make files and then Make invokes the compiler and the linker. So in this case, you tell CMake you want Ninja files and then you run the Ninja command and Ninja invokes the compiler and the linker for you. And it has very, like, it's not much time to transition over. I've not needed to fidget with it, so I can't say much about the configurability of it. But I found it to be like pretty efficient. And everybody that on our team who has tried it has ended up pretty much just switching to it. And it's pretty no
让我困惑，无论如何，但你有一个cmake。CMake制作Make文件，然后Make调用编译器和链接器。所以在这个例子中，你告诉CMake你想要Ninja文件，然后你运行Ninja命令，Ninja为你调用编译器和链接器。而且它非常，就像，过渡时间不多。我不需要摆弄它，所以我不能说它的可配置性。但我发现它相当高效。我们团队中尝试过它的每个人最终都几乎只是切换到了它。而且它非常
nonsense and has a pretty nice output. So it looks it looks good. And it runs on in parallel by default. And it's really easy to build only specific binaries if your project builds multiple binaries. So if you've not tried it out before, and especially if you're using CMake, it's really easy to build only specific binaries if your project builds multiple binaries. So if you've not tried it out before, and especially if you're using CMake, it's as easy as just passing, I believe it's the dash, no, I don't know. Dash G. Is it dash G?
不废话，并且有一个相当不错的输出。所以它看起来不错。而且它默认并行运行。如果你构建多个二进制文件，只构建特定的二进制文件也非常容易。所以如果你以前没有尝试过，特别是如果你在使用CMake，只构建特定的二进制文件也非常容易。所以如果你以前没有尝试过，特别是如果你在使用CMake，就像传递，我相信是破折号，不，我不知道。破折号G。是破折号G吗？
Dash G Ninja with a capital N. And so if you're using CMake, definitely try having an output Ninja and check it out. Yeah, Ninja is amazing. I highly, highly recommend everyone switch to Ninja. Yeah. You know, the interesting thing about make is if you do make dash J, but you don't provide a number, it just blows up your computer basically. Like, yeah. So make dash J with no number sets it to infinity. No. Yeah. So, so if you have to build, let's say 300 files, it will spin up 300 processes right then and there
破折号G Ninja，大写N。所以如果你在使用CMake，一定要尝试让它输出Ninja并看看。是的，Ninja太棒了。我强烈强烈推荐每个人都切换到Ninja。是的。你知道，关于make有趣的事情是，如果你做make -J，但你不提供数字，它基本上会炸掉你的电脑。就像，是的。所以没有数字的make -J会把它设置为无穷大。不。是的。所以，如果你必须构建，比如说300个文件，它会立即启动300个进程
and try and build everything at once. So I guess if you have a small project, that's fine. But if you have a big project, yeah, that seems bad. Yeah, I mean, you know, even Eternal Turtle is not even that big. And actually, the thing that got me to switch to Ninja was that I did make-j. I was in a hurry, and I meant to do make-j 4. And I forgot I didn't get the 4 in a hurry and I meant to do make dash J four. And I just, I forgot,
并尝试一次构建所有东西。所以我猜如果你有一个小项目，那没关系。但如果你有一个大项目，是的，那看起来很糟糕。是的，我的意思是，你知道，即使Eternal Terminal也不是那么大。实际上，让我切换到Ninja的原因是我做了make -J。我当时很匆忙，我本打算做make -J 4。我忘了，我没来得及得到4，我本打算做make -J 4。我只是，我忘了，
I didn't get the four in time and I had to restart my computer. And I was just like, this is so, this is so dumb. There's one thing actually, um, is that the reason why I hadn't been using ninjas is having to pass the dash G to see make all the time. But I found there is a C make config you can set somewhere in your home directory and if you do
我没来得及得到4，我不得不重启我的电脑。我当时就想，这太，这太蠢了。实际上有一件事，嗯，就是我没有使用Ninja的原因是必须一直向cmake传递-G。但我发现有一个CMake配置你可以在你的主目录中的某个地方设置，如果你这样做
that it will always run ninja by default i guess i always tailor my build anyways i always have other flags to pass in like dash d flags for defining like how i want the build to configure so passing one more uh makes sense because i just go into my history and edit my last run so yeah but yeah that's good to know i didn't know you could put in defaults into the cmake cool yeah totally yeah ninja is great everyone should should definitely jump on that if you're using make where everyone is a small subset of people that are building cnc plus plus and listening to the show and have a cmake front end i would say that's maybe 8 000 people or something i don't know maybe 10 000 we need. We need a poll. All right. Yeah. Yeah. If you're using
它会默认一直运行Ninja，我想我总是调整我的构建，无论如何，我总是还有其他标志要传递，比如用于定义我想要构建如何配置的-D标志，所以再传递一个是有意义的，因为我只是进入我的历史记录并编辑我上次的运行，所以是的，但是的，很高兴知道，我不知道你可以把默认值放入cmake，酷。是的，完全同意。是的，Ninja很棒，如果你们在使用make，每个人都应该绝对跳上那辆车，如果每个人都是构建C和C++并听这个节目且有一个CMake前端的一小部分人，我会说那可能是8000人左右，我不知道，也许10000人，我们需要。我们需要一个民意调查。好的。是的。是的。如果你在使用
CMake, let us know. Actually, if you switched to Ninja and like it, definitely let us know. Cool. On to Kotlin. So. Oh, yeah, go ahead. So the first time I heard about Kotlin was in the context of people saying you could now develop Android apps. And I hadn't heard much about it before. But I was interested to learn that I assumed it was made by, you know, I guess it would have been Sun slash Cisco as an extension of Java, because it got picked up by Google for doing Android stuff. But I was surprised to learn that Kotlin actually came out of the JetBrains team, which are the people who make IntelliJ, CLion, and a number of... Is it Py... One of the Python tools. Which Python tool is it? I was going to say PyCharm, but I don't think that's correct.
CMake，让我们知道。实际上，如果你切换到Ninja并喜欢它，一定要让我们知道。酷。进入Kotlin。所以。哦，是的，继续。所以第一次听说Kotlin是在人们说你现在可以开发Android应用程序的背景下。我之前没怎么听说过它。但我很有兴趣了解到，我假设它是Sun/Cisco制造的，作为Java的扩展，因为它被Google选中用于做Android的东西。但我很惊讶地了解到Kotlin实际上来自JetBrains团队，也就是制作IntelliJ、CLion和许多……是Py……其中一个Python工具。是哪个Python工具？我本来想说是PyCharm，但我不认为那是对的。
No. Yeah. I know what you're talking about, though. Is it MyPy? Oh, man. No. Anyway, so they make a lot of... Yeah, it is PyCharm. They make PyCharm. Cool. Oh, they do. Okay. Yeah. And so they make a lot of tools yeah it is pycharm they make pycharm cool oh they do okay yeah and so they make a lot of tools that a lot of people have heard of um so if you're not just using i mean i guess if you're a power user and using emacs or or vi you know more power to you if you're using an ide it's likely you've run across uh one of the jet brains and if you haven't i encourage you to try out they're not um there's often free versions, but they're not always free. But if you work for a company, most of the time, most people's company
不。是的。但我知道你在说什么。是MyPy吗？哦，天哪。不。总之，所以他们制作了很多……是的，是PyCharm。他们制作PyCharm。酷。哦，他们做到了。好的。是的。所以他们制作了很多工具，是的，是PyCharm，他们制作PyCharm。酷。哦，他们做到了。好的。是的。所以他们制作了很多工具，很多人都听说过，嗯，所以如果你不仅仅是在使用，我的意思是，我猜如果你是一个高级用户并使用emacs或vi，你知道，如果你使用IDE，你很可能遇到过JetBrains的工具，如果你没有，我鼓励你尝试一下，它们不是……通常有免费版本，但它们并不总是免费的。但如果你为一家公司工作，大多数时候，大多数人的公司
will pay for using the tools. And I would say JetBrains tooling is really good. And they were the ones who actually started Kotlin and then open sourced it. Yeah, I was really shocked to learn that almost half the people using Kotlin are not writing Android apps. They're doing a lot of web backend.
会支付使用这些工具的费用。而且我会说JetBrains的工具非常好。而且他们实际上是开始Kotlin然后开源它的人。是的，我真的很震惊地了解到，几乎一半使用Kotlin的人并没有在写Android应用程序。他们在做很多Web后端。
And yeah, that was super, super surprising to me. Yeah, I mean, I'll have to really dive into that. I mean, actually, I could see the rationale because if you already have a web frontend in Java, that's definitely the easiest migration to make or a web backend rather. But yeah, so yeah, I think another thing that made Kotlin really, really popular
而且，是的，这对我来说超级超级惊讶。是的，我的意思是，我将不得不真正深入研究这一点。我的意思是，实际上，我可以理解其中的理由，因为如果你已经有一个Java的Web前端，那绝对是最容易进行的迁移，或者说是Web后端。但是的，所以，是的，我认为另一件让Kotlin变得非常非常受欢迎的事情
was this whole drama around Java, the Java APIs. So this, and actually, Patrick, I don't know, you might know a lot more about this than I do, but ostensibly there was this issue where I think like Oracle kind of owned Java, but you can't really own a programming language. You can only own, I guess, certain APIs. And there's this whole back and forth
是围绕Java，Java API的整个戏剧。所以这个，实际上，帕特里克，我不知道，你可能比我知道得多得多，但表面上有一个问题，我想Oracle有点拥有Java，但你不能真正拥有编程语言。你只能拥有，我想，某些API。而且有整个来回
between Oracle and Google, who are the people who make Android. And I just feel like Kotlin was probably part of that whole, I mean, Kotlin is definitely, I think, better for Android development. But I think part of it too, is sort of strategic. Yeah, I mean, that whole thing is still I think still in in the court. But I feel like I don't want to address it without prepping myself, even though I feel like I know what the situation is, because it becomes pretty, pretty subtle. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. But you know, I think that that, you know, Colin has a lot of
在Oracle和Google之间，也就是制作Android的人。我只是觉得Kotlin可能就是整个事情的一部分，我的意思是，Kotlin绝对，我认为，对Android开发更好。但我认为部分原因也是，某种战略性的。是的，我的意思是，整件事我认为仍然在法庭上。但我感觉我不想在没有准备的情况下解决它，即使我觉得我知道情况是什么，因为它变得非常非常微妙。是的，这说得通。是的。但你知道，我认为，你知道，Kotlin有很多
really nice features. So, you know, for one thing, if you're building a front end, and this is, you know, my personal take, if you're building a front end, that tends to be the place where you really need type inference. Because you're dealing with a lot of callbacks. And so things can get, like type inference, lambda functions, these things become most important, at least for me in the front end. And like, like, for example, like eternal terminal doesn't really need, you know, async or anything like that, because it just does one thing, right. But but on the front end, you have all these different buttons and switches, and everything kind of needs to be asynchronous. And so and so that's where, you know, these kind of language properties really shine. And Colin's very good at that. You know, being a JVM language, it's fully compatible with, you know, Clojure, Script,
非常好的功能。所以，你知道，一方面，如果你在构建前端，这是，你知道，我的个人看法，如果你在构建前端，那往往是你真正需要类型推断的地方。因为你在处理很多回调。所以事情可能会变得，比如类型推断，lambda函数，这些东西变得最重要，至少对我来说是在前端。而且，比如，比如，Eternal Terminal并不真正需要，你知道，异步或类似的东西，因为它只是做一件事，对吧。但但在前端，你有所有这些不同的按钮和开关，一切都需要是异步的。所以，所以这就是，你知道，这些语言属性真正闪光的地方。而且Kotlin在这方面非常擅长。你知道，作为一种JVM语言，它与，你知道，Clojure Script完全兼容，
which we've talked about on past shows, and obviously Java and Scala and all those other languages, which is really nice. But another really cool feature about Kotlin is it also interops with Objective-C and Swift. So it's entirely possible for you to have like a Android app in Kotlin
我们在过去的节目中谈到过，显然还有Java和Scala以及所有其他语言，这非常好。但Kotlin的另一个非常酷的功能是它也与Objective-C和Swift互操作。所以你完全有可能拥有一个Kotlin编写的Android应用程序
and then let's say you feel compelled to write the iOS version of the same app, you could at least move a lot of the business logic over and then you would write using the interop, you would write the front endop you would write you know the the the front end um in swift let's say but but all of your business logic that sits on the on the phone could could be shared uh between android and ios which is really appealing actually reading through kotlin and having done some swift i found like it actually feels almost like they are targeting
然后假设你觉得有必要编写同一个应用程序的iOS版本，你至少可以移动很多业务逻辑，然后你会使用互操作，你会编写，你知道，前端，你会编写，你知道，前端，嗯，用Swift，比如说，但你所有的业务逻辑，坐在手机上的，都可以被共享，在Android和iOS之间，这实际上非常有吸引力。实际上阅读Kotlin并做了一些Swift，我发现它实际上感觉几乎就像他们瞄准的是
the same trade-offs. So if they feel very similar to me, obviously Swift wasn't meant to be like a JVM based language, even though I believe that now Kotlin also can be a front-end to LLVM. And so you can build it without the JVM. But Swift and Kotlin, the syntax itself is different, like the operators you use and the words. But the way, like how constant versus non-constant variables are done, how that stuff is strongly typed, but if the type can be easily inferred, you don't have to write it. These kinds of things feel very similar between the two to me. Yeah, that makes
相同的权衡。所以如果它们对我来说感觉非常相似，显然Swift并不是要成为一种基于JVM的语言，即使我相信现在Kotlin也可以是LLVM的前端。所以你可以在没有JVM的情况下构建它。但Swift和Kotlin，语法本身是不同的，比如你使用的运算符和单词。但方式，比如常量与非常量变量是如何完成的，这些东西是如何强类型的，但如果类型可以很容易地推断出来，你就不必写它。这些东西对我来说在两者之间感觉非常相似。是的，这说得通。
sense. I mean, one thing that Kotlin, that I wanted to call out about Kotlin is they borrowed the data class idea from Python, which I really like. There was a period of time where I would basically use protobuf on everything that I built, even if I didn't need it. And the reason is because the code that protobuf generated was so convenient. Like I could take any C++ class, I could turn it into a string, I could turn it back into a class, I could compare things.
我的意思是，Kotlin的一件事，我想关于Kotlin指出的，是他们借用了Python的数据类想法，我真的很喜欢。有一段时间，我基本上在我构建的任何东西上都使用protobuf，即使我不需要它。原因是因为protobuf生成的代码非常方便。就像我可以拿任何C++类，我可以把它变成一个字符串，我可以把它变回一个类，我可以比较东西。
I didn't have to write any of the comparators, right? And at least the way I think when I program is I have some classes that are just holding data. And then I have other classes that are procedures and processes. And so I'll typically have a widget class that has a whole bunch of different properties. And then I'll have a widget runner class that uh you know is empty in terms of storage but just has a lot of logic and and then the widget class like you have to end up implementing the hash function the comparator function all these things right so um you know with python and i don't know who who kind of came up with this first so i could the arrow of causality could go in the other direction.
我不需要写任何比较器，对吧？而且至少我编程时的思考方式是，我有一些类只是持有数据。然后我有其他类是程序和过程。所以我通常会有一个widget类，它有许多不同的属性。然后我会有widget runner类，它，嗯，你知道，在存储方面是空的，但只是有很多逻辑，然后widget类，你最终必须实现哈希函数、比较器函数，所有这些东西，对吧？所以，嗯，你知道，用Python，我不知道是谁先想出这个的，所以我因果关系的箭头可以朝另一个方向。
But with Python, you have this awesome import called data class. And you can annotate a class as a data class. And you could choose for it to be frozen or not frozen. And so then what happens is if I have a data class, let's say, called point, which has an X and a Y for the coordinates, I can create this sort of point class, I could print it, and it'll just print X colon Y colon automatically without me having to write that I could serialize a bunch of points to disk and then get them back. It's just a really nice kind of setup. And if I choose to make a frozen data class, then I can't actually change, let's say, the x coordinate.
但用Python，你有一个很棒的导入叫data class。你可以将一个类注释为数据类。你可以选择它是冻结的还是不冻结的。所以发生的情况是，如果我有一个数据类，比如说，叫point，它有一个X和一个Y坐标，我可以创建这种point类，我可以打印它，它会自动打印X冒号Y冒号，而不需要我写，我可以将一堆点序列化到磁盘，然后把它们拿回来。这只是一个非常好的设置。如果我选择制作一个冻结的数据类，那么我就不能真正改变，比如说，x坐标。
So I can't do my point dot x plus plus. That's illegal, right? But because it's frozen and you have to make a new point anytime you change something, it's immutable. Then there's other sort of optimizations they can do that are really attractive, right? Like you could put it into a, you could use it as a key in a dictionary, for example. And Kotlin takes this data class idea and brings it over, which I think makes development a lot easier. That's pretty cool. I did not know about this data class in Python. So that's a valuable tip right there. They do have something similar in Java, they have a couple different ones. I know one of them is called like Lombok, which is like it integrates with your sort of ID and build system. And you produce it's kind of like what you're saying, I guess, like simplified class descriptions, they get transpiled into like
所以我不能做我的point.x++。那是违法的，对吧？但因为它是冻结的，而且你每次改变东西时都必须制作一个新的点，它是不可变的。那么还有其他类型的优化他们可以做，这非常有吸引力，对吧？比如你可以把它放入一个，你可以把它用作字典中的键，例如。而且Kotlin采用了这个数据类想法并把它带过来，我认为这让开发变得容易得多。这很酷。我不知道Python中的这个数据类。所以这是一个非常有价值的提示。他们在Java中确实有类似的东西，他们有几个不同的。我知道其中一个叫Lombok，它集成到你的IDE和构建系统中。而且你生成它有点像你说的，我猜，比如简化的类描述，它们被转译成
all the boiler boilerplate code. So like standard Java, you're not supposed to like directly access the variables, you're supposed to have getters and setters for everything like that's kind of accepted. And writing those out is super tedious. And like you said, the hashes and the to string. So instead, they allow you to write like a very simple description and say that you want all those things to be generated, and then it'll just auto generate it for you nice so is there like in c++ is there an equivalent for this what is that called it's that no but kind of yes um it's oh i think it's hang on i want to check i think it's is there marshmallow there's a way to do it with macros yeah i think there's marsh marshmallow is a thing that also exists in python but but i think marshmallow originated from c++ and that might be one way
所有的样板代码。所以，比如标准Java，你不应该直接访问变量，你应该有getter和setter，对于所有这些，就像那是被接受的。而且写出这些超级乏味。而且就像你说的，哈希和to string。所以相反，他们允许你写一个非常简单的描述，并说你想要生成所有这些东西，然后它就会自动为你生成它。不错，那么在C++中是否有等价物？那叫什么？它不是，但有点是，嗯，它，哦，我想是，等等，我想检查一下，我想是，是否有marshmallow？有一种方法可以用宏来做，是的，我想有marshmallow，marshmallow也是Python中存在的东西，但，但我认为marshmallow起源于C++，那可能是一种方法
to do it so i think the way if you're going to do something like this in c++ but i it's generally fun it's called x macro i was thinking x args and i knew x args was wrong x macro um but all it is is uh sort of including but you can kind of do the same thing but it's all with pre-processor macros which if you've used c or c plus plus before i mean using a lot of macros can get you into trouble uh to make sure it's pretty hard to read so i definitely wouldn't recommend doing it but that's the main way i've seen it be done at like a code level. Obviously, like you're, you're saying Jason, like a lot of people use sort of protobuf or something similar to that, like another IDL kind of like description of data description language,
来做它，所以我认为如果你要在C++中做这样的事情，但我，它通常很有趣，它叫X宏，我当时在想X args，我知道X args是错的，X宏，但它只是，嗯，某种包含，但你可以做同样的事情，但它都是用预处理器宏，如果你以前使用过C或C++，我的意思是，使用大量宏会让你陷入麻烦，确保它很难阅读，所以我绝对不会建议这样做，但这是我看到它在代码层面完成的主要方式。显然，就像你，你在说Jason，很多人使用某种protobuf或类似的东西，比如另一个IDL，有点像数据描述语言的描述，
which is an external tool. And it doesn't really integrate at a code level the same way. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah. I mean, I think protobuf would be the way to go. I think, as you said, you know, it's so frustrating when you, you know, like control click on a class member variable and it takes you to like a pound define that, you know, is unrolling 20 different ways and you have to go and chase it down.
这是一个外部工具。而且它并没有真正以同样的方式在代码层面集成。是的，这说得通。是的。我的意思是，我认为protobuf会是最好的选择。我认为，正如你所说，你知道，当你，你知道，比如控制点击一个类成员变量，它带你到一个pound define，你知道，正在以20种不同的方式展开，你必须去追查它，这太令人沮丧了。
Cool, so yeah, I think, you know, just some, you know, since Kotlin, you know, Kotlin, wait, Kotlin is used for Android development and mobile development. It's good to talk a little bit about developing for mobile. Actually, have you ever, I've built some apps in the past, none of them were super popular, but, you know, definitely not an app building expert. But a few things that I kind of learned along the way, the biggest one was not to block the main thread. So it's very tempting to write in this procedural way. It's like, okay, I click the button. Now I have a whole bunch of logic to do. I want to go to a database. And when I get the results from the database, I want to show it on the screen. But that ends up creating this really bad experience. And you've probably seen this.
酷，所以是的，我想，你知道，只是，你知道，因为 Kotlin，你知道，Kotlin，等等，Kotlin 是用于 Android 开发和移动开发的。谈谈移动开发其实挺好的。说实话，你有没有，我过去做过一些应用，虽然都不怎么火，但我绝对不是应用开发专家。不过我在过程中学到了一些东西，最重要的一点就是不要阻塞主线程。以这种过程式的方式编写代码非常诱人。就像是，好的，我点击了按钮。现在我有一堆逻辑要处理。我想访问数据库。当我从数据库得到结果时，我想把它显示在屏幕上。但这最终会导致非常糟糕的体验。你可能也见过这种情况。
I think iOS actually won't let you do this. So it's like it won't like the language, like Objective-C will somehow just not let you do it. But on Android, you can see this where even if you have a really high end phone, if the app is not written in a good way, like it could kind of stutter or the app can freeze while it's doing some logic. That's true, not even just on mobile. I mean, that's true even on the desktop. In general, you don't want to do that. Yep.
我觉得 iOS 其实不允许你这样做。所以就像是它不会，语言本身，比如 Objective-C，会以某种方式阻止你这样做。但在 Android 上，你可以看到这种情况，即使你用的是高端手机，如果应用写得不好，它可能会卡顿，或者在处理逻辑时应用会冻结。没错，这不仅仅是在移动端。我的意思是，即使在桌面上也是如此。通常情况下，你都不想那样做。是的。
Yeah, totally. And so Kotlin makes this easy by introducing coroutines. So typically, before Kotlin, if you're doing this in java for example um you'd have to have a bunch of threads right and you'd have to have a thread pool and you'd have to say well you know the person clicked on the button so um you know go to my thread pool and and and spin up this this thread that you know does some sort of logic. And it ends up being a lot of boilerplate. With coroutines, coroutines are at a high level.
是的，完全正确。所以 Kotlin 通过引入协程（coroutines）让这一切变得简单。通常在 Kotlin 之前，如果你用 Java 做这些事，比如，嗯，你必须要有大量的线程，对吧？你必须有一个线程池，你必须说，好吧，你知道，用户点击了按钮，所以，嗯，你知道，去我的线程池，然后启动这个线程，你知道，去做某种逻辑。这最终会产生大量的样板代码。有了协程，协程处于一个很高的抽象层级。
You could think of it as kind of like a thread pool, but it's built into the language at a pretty fundamental level. So it's kind of like a first-class citizen. And so instead of you maintaining your own thread pool, you could just say, hey, you know, do this thing asynchronously. And and the language itself handles, you're doing tutorials seems like something that I kind of almost envy, like, coming from a background of developing, like mostly command line utilities and stuff, seeing something like Android Studio and its support for Kotlin and having the backend and like out of the box doing just amazing, like auto completions and suggestions and the usefulness is something that
你可以把它看作是一种线程池，但它在语言层面被相当基础地内置了。所以它就像是一等公民。因此，你不需要维护自己的线程池，你只需要说，嘿，你知道，异步执行这个任务。语言本身会处理，你做的教程看起来像是我几乎羡慕的东西，比如，从开发背景来看，大多是命令行工具之类的，看到像 Android Studio 及其对 Kotlin 的支持，拥有后端，并且开箱即用，做着令人惊叹的事情，比如自动补全和建议，这种实用性是...
Kotlin comes with and being actually, I believe it's kind of like the recommended way now to build Android apps, like they don't even like you just go to their web page, and you know, kind of follow the default, like make your first Android app, it will have you develop it in Kotlin with Android Studio. Yeah, totally. You know, a IDEs have these RAD tools, rapid application development. And basically what that is, it's a fancy way of saying it's like a little editor where you can kind of drag and drop buttons and drop down lists and combo boxes and all these things. And you can actually get a lot done in the editor. And then typically the editor has this like two-way is bi-directional mapping to either the source code or some kind of XML or JSON file.
Kotlin 自带的，而且实际上，我相信这现在是构建 Android 应用的推荐方式，比如他们甚至不希望你，你只需要去他们的网页，然后，你知道，按照默认设置，比如制作你的第一个 Android 应用，它会让你在 Android Studio 中使用 Kotlin 进行开发。是的，完全正确。你知道，IDE 有这些 RAD 工具，即快速应用开发。基本上，这是一种花哨的说法，意思是它就像一个小编辑器，你可以拖放按钮、下拉列表、组合框以及所有这些东西。你实际上可以在编辑器中完成很多工作。然后通常编辑器具有这种双向映射，映射到源代码或某种 XML 或 JSON 文件。
And so, for example, if you're doing Qt on desktop, you can use Qt creator and it will create this.ui file. And that.ui file kind of explains the layout of your application. And then you just have to sort of plug into all the buttons. And so you don't have to encode, write, draw a button and put it over here. You don't have to do that by hand. You could just use the editor. And so for mobile, this is really, really important because, you know, a lot of what you're going to be doing on mobile is on the design side.
所以，例如，如果你在桌面上使用 Qt，你可以使用 Qt Creator，它会创建一个 .ui 文件。那个 .ui 文件解释了你应用程序的布局。然后你只需要把所有按钮连接起来。所以你不必编码，写代码，画一个按钮并把它放在这里。你不必手动做这些。你只需要使用编辑器。所以对于移动端来说，这非常非常重要，因为，你知道，你在移动端要做的很多事情都是在设计层面。
And so, you know, having a RAD tool like that is extremely useful and makes you much, much more productive. And also, you know, it'll kind of force you to separate the, you know, layout and the visual, you know, design from the business logic. It'll kind of force you to separate the you know layout and the and the visual you know design from the the business logic it'll kind of force you to do that which is a really good you know healthy practice to have i mean the other thing that the the tooling like that i guess is like now well i guess used to be the big thing like on ios you had very few form factors and on android you had tons but not everyone just seems like they've given up and gone to what is it called like adaptive UI or whatever, like UI, basically, like flowing and changing based on like, you know, kind of smoothly across a range of
所以，你知道，拥有这样一个 RAD 工具非常有用，能让你效率高得多。而且，你知道，它会强迫你将布局和视觉设计与业务逻辑分离开来。它会强迫你这样做，这是一种非常好的、健康的实践。我的意思是，这种工具的另一个好处是，嗯，我想现在，嗯，我想过去在 iOS 上是大热门，你有很少的几种外形尺寸，而在 Android 上你有无数种，但每个人似乎都放弃了，转向了所谓的自适应 UI 之类的，也就是 UI，基本上，随着范围的变化而平滑流动和改变。
resolutions and sizes. And I feel like doing that stuff by hand becomes like, very difficult. And having the these tools, although some people kind of want that pixel perfect layout and sometimes it's still supported but using these tools in general especially for new people and making sure it's going to work across the right range of assumptions these tools are vital to be able to help you do that yep yep yeah totally i think um you some more mobile development stuff is kind of interesting is is um you have to deal with signing your app. So a lot of these apps, when someone goes to get your app from either the app store or maybe they download it from a website, they download the APK file, they want to make of that. They'll integrate with ProGuard. ProGuard is this tool which kind of prevents people from decompiling your app and then kind of taking away your source code and all of that,
分辨率和尺寸。我觉得手动做这些事情变得非常困难。拥有这些工具，尽管有些人想要那种像素完美的布局，有时仍然支持，但总的来说，使用这些工具，特别是对于新手，并确保它能在正确的假设范围内工作，这些工具对于帮助你完成这些工作至关重要。是的，是的，完全正确。我想，嗯，你更多关于移动开发的东西挺有趣的，是，嗯，你必须处理应用的签名。所以很多这些应用，当有人去应用商店获取你的应用，或者可能从网站下载时，他们下载 APK 文件，他们想确保这一点。他们会与 ProGuard 集成。ProGuard 是一个工具，它能防止人们反编译你的应用，然后拿走你的源代码以及所有这些，
extracting the source code out of it. And so there's a whole bunch that goes into deploying an app that you really don't think about when you're building something, let's say, when you're building something, let's say, when you're building a website or something. And so the IDE does a really good job of handling a lot of that versus the web where on the web, you have to go get Webpack and run it and figure out how that works and everything. And there are frameworks like Next.js, which we talked about, you know, with Guillermo Rauch on a past episode, which will, you know, do a lot of that for you. But here, I think a lot of that, the IDE just makes that even more easier where you can just kind of click a button and all these things happen in the background.
提取其中的源代码。所以部署一个应用涉及很多你构建东西时根本不会想到的事情，比如，当你构建一个网站之类的东西时。所以 IDE 在处理这些方面做得非常好，而 Web 则不同，在 Web 上，你必须去获取 Webpack，运行它，弄清楚它是如何工作的等等。虽然有一些框架，比如 Next.js，我们在过去的一期节目中和 Guillermo Rauch 讨论过，它会为你做很多这些事情。但在这里，我认为 IDE 让这一切变得更加容易，你只需要点击一个按钮，所有这些事情都会在后台发生。
Kind of off of the developing for mobile, but one of the things that came up recently at work that that i saw you know sort of kotlin kotlin has a way of dealing with was talking about optionals and i was talking before about similarity to to swift but in in kotlin like by default your variables can't be set to null and if you want them to be set to null then you need to declare them as nullable which is analogous to the optional. It's a kind of different way of saying it. And if you have a type which you're dealing with a variable which is nullable,
稍微偏离一下移动开发的话题，最近在工作中出现的一件事，我看到 Kotlin 处理的一种方式是关于可选类型（optionals），我之前谈到了与 Swift 的相似之处，但在 Kotlin 中，默认情况下你的变量不能设置为 null，如果你想让它们被设置为 null，那么你需要将它们声明为可空类型（nullable），这类似于可选类型。这是一种不同的说法。如果你处理的类型是一个可空的变量，
you're basically Kotlin forces you to handle it. So you either have to say, I'm choosing to ignore it, which is bad, don't do that. Or you have to say basically what the behavior should be normally and what the behavior should be normally and what the behavior should be, if it's currently null. And Swift has something similar for optionals, which is, you know, if the optional is not there, it's missing, then that's a specifically handled case
基本上 Kotlin 会强迫你处理它。所以你要么说，我选择忽略它，这很糟糕，不要这样做。或者你必须基本上说明正常情况下应该是什么行为，以及如果它当前为 null 时应该是什么行为。Swift 在可选类型方面也有类似的东西，即，你知道，如果可选值不存在，它是缺失的，那么这是一个专门处理的情况，
versus if it's there, and it's set to some value. And I feel we were talking about this, you know, coming up at work and talking about how like, this flow being preferable to kind of previously, people might have done something similar with like, kind of throwing exceptions in Java, right, you might throw an exception that, oh, I couldn't, I couldn't parse this into tokens, the string couldn't be parsed into tokens, throw an exception. And that for control flow was considered acceptable. But now you might, I guess more the style or the current more preferred way would be maybe you return a whatever container of tokens, but that container is wrapped in an optional or in this case, sort of nullable. And then if you know that the person is forced to handle the case where the thing itself is missing, not just like, so you can get no tokens, you can get some set of tokens, or you can get this state where it says basically, like, I failed to do I failed to fulfill what you asked me to do.
而不是它存在且被设置为某个值的情况。我觉得我们当时在讨论这个，你知道，在工作中提到，谈论这种流程如何比以前更可取，人们可能用类似在 Java 中抛出异常的方式做过类似的事情，对吧？你可能会抛出一个异常，哦，我无法解析这个字符串，字符串无法解析为标记，抛出一个异常。这在控制流中被认为是可接受的。但现在你可能会，我想更多的是风格或当前更偏好的方式可能是你返回某种标记容器，但该容器被包装在可选类型中，或者在这种情况下，是可空类型。然后如果你知道用户被迫处理该事物本身缺失的情况，不仅仅是，所以你可以得到没有标记，你可以得到一组标记，或者你可以得到这种状态，它基本上说，我无法完成你要求我做的事情。
And then people can take applicable handling, and it's expressed in the type directly, because it's wrapped around with this either nullable or wrapped as an optional. And we were just talking about how like that's become more popular i think it comes out of kind of like the functional programming world um this is super super common but it's it's gained a lot of traction to the point where i feel like it's almost become like the recommend recommended way and i and seeing kotlin here is uh you know i guess like a decade old but you know, I guess, like a tech aid all but you know, more recently developed language has a direct support for this flow. And I feel like that's just a really good thing. Like, I kind of wish I had that in C++, like a way to force me to handle this this way for things which could be null and the language sort of supported it sort of nicely and directly because I feel it's a good design and direction personally often. Yeah, yeah, totally makes sense.
然后人们可以采取适当的处理，它直接在类型中表达出来，因为它被包装在这个可空类型或可选类型中。我们刚才在讨论这变得越来越流行，我想它源于函数式编程世界，这非常非常普遍，但它已经获得了很大的吸引力，以至于我觉得它几乎成了推荐的方式。而且看到 Kotlin 在这里，嗯，你知道，我猜它有十年历史了，但你知道，更近开发的语言对这种流程有直接支持。我觉得这真是一件好事。就像，我真希望我在 C++ 中也有这个，一种强迫我以这种方式处理可能为 null 的事物的方法，而且语言本身能很好地直接支持它，因为我个人认为这是一个很好的设计和方向。是的，是的，完全说得通。
Yeah, I was noticing this as I was going through and integrating the internal terminal with Sentry. One of the things that I noticed was that if I caught an error, but it was actually like a fatal error, I just caught it somewhere else and then ended up rethrowing it or it caused problems downstream those were actually the hardest to learn anything from like it was the hardest to really instrument because because you know it's like you don't really know what went wrong like the easiest things instrument instrument are the ones where you just die instantly like you say like this
是的，我在集成内部终端和 Sentry 时注意到了这一点。我注意到的一件事是，如果我捕获了一个错误，但它实际上是一个致命错误，我只是在其他地方捕获了它，然后最终重新抛出它，或者它在下游导致了问题，这些实际上是最难从中学习任何东西的，因为，你知道，这就像你真的不知道出了什么问题。最容易检测的是那些你直接死掉的情况，比如你说，这个
something really bad happened i'm out and here's the stack trace like those are the best but you know not not every error kind of fits into that category as you said like there might be this time where you're tokenizing something and if if the tokens aren't correct you just want to return null and there's a way to handle it that isn't so dramatic right and and a lot of those you know I used to just throw and then catch somewhere else. And that became really difficult to diagnose because it's very hard to actually know where it's going to get caught. But if you instead go this route of returning null, then you might have to handle it in more places. But the trade-off is you end up with a clean flow.
发生了非常糟糕的事情，我退出了，这是堆栈跟踪，这些是最好的。但你知道，并非每个错误都属于那一类，正如你所说，可能存在这种时候，你在对某事进行标记化，如果标记不正确，你只想返回 null，有一种处理方式并不那么戏剧化，对吧？而且很多那些，你知道，我过去只是抛出异常，然后在某处捕获。这变得非常难以诊断，因为很难真正知道它会在哪里被捕获。但如果你改为返回 null 的路线，那么你可能不得不在更多地方处理它。但权衡是，你最终会得到一个清晰的流程。
And when, let's say if one of those places just can't deal with that null and it has to crash the whole app, like that's actually where the problem is, not those other places that just handled the null just fine, right? So yeah, actually you mentioned this in an earlier episode, Patrick,
当，假设如果其中一个地方无法处理那个 null，它必须让整个应用崩溃，那实际上才是问题所在，而不是那些处理 null 处理得很好的其他地方，对吧？所以是的，其实你在之前的一期节目中提到过这一点，Patrick，
about how there's a certain style i don't know if you follow it or if you're at a place that followed it where they they just don't throw anything they just don't throw exceptions yeah this is fine being in c plus that's sort of the recommended way i i was pointing out someone brought this up literally a few days ago and i was saying you know as far as know, I haven't seen a lot of sort of high level C++ people, professionals sort of recommend use of throwing and catching in C++. It's just generally either inefficient or just hasn't been rolled out. Like it's just not an accepted way of doing things. So yeah, we actually don't allow throwing in our code. Yeah, I think it's a way to
关于有一种特定的风格，我不知道你是否遵循它，或者你是否在一个遵循它的地方，他们只是不抛出任何东西，他们只是不抛出异常。是的，这在 C++ 中是推荐的方式。我指出有人几天前才提到这一点，我说，你知道，据我所知，我还没有看到很多高水平的 C++ 人士、专业人士推荐在 C++ 中使用抛出和捕获。它通常要么效率低下，要么还没有被推广。就像它根本不是一种被接受的做事方式。所以是的，我们实际上不允许在我们的代码中抛出异常。是的，我认为这是一个方向。
go. I mean, in hindsight, you know, and the nice thing there too is, you know, occasionally the language will throw an exception, you know, like you do A equals zero, B equals C divided by A, boom, exception, right? And if you don't catch those, the default behavior, you can catch the signal, you can intercept that signal, and then you will get a stack trace and a whole bunch of really useful information. So not catching the exception can result in some really detailed information that could be actually a lot more useful than catching the exception and then exiting. And then now you end up with not the right information, it becomes very hard to fix.
我的意思是，事后看来，你知道，而且那里好的地方还在于，你知道，偶尔语言会抛出一个异常，你知道，比如你做 A 等于 0，B 等于 C 除以 A，砰，异常，对吧？如果你不捕获那些，默认行为，你可以捕获信号，你可以拦截那个信号，然后你会得到一个堆栈跟踪和一大堆非常有用的信息。所以不捕获异常可能会导致一些非常详细的信息，这实际上可能比捕获异常然后退出更有用。然后现在你得到的信息不对，这变得非常难以修复。
Yeah, I think I'm not doing active Java development anymore, but it feels like in Java, it used to be more common to have, I guess they call it checked exceptions, where if your function knew it would throw an exception, people would need to handle it and potentially pass it up. I feel now the style is more to do a runtime exception where you extend, you inherit from runtime exception, and then people aren't forced to catch it. um like you're saying if your os signals that's a runtime exception like
是的，我想我不再进行主动的 Java 开发了，但感觉在 Java 中，过去更常见的是有，我想他们称之为受检异常（checked exceptions），如果你的函数知道它会抛出异常，人们就需要处理它并可能将其向上传递。我觉得现在的风格更多是做运行时异常，你扩展，继承自运行时异常，然后人们就不会被迫去捕获它。嗯，就像你说的，如果你的操作系统发出信号，那是一个运行时异常，就像
it's not a compiled time you you don't you never know what could cause your os to throw an exception because you could just be kill dash nine from something else right so you never know what all actually i don't know if that makes anyways separate topic you never know what all actually, I don't know if that makes anyways, separate topic, you never know what a signal not an exception, but I think you're you have the right spirit. Yeah, so so you never know what could just like flake out runtime. Similarly, if you get into some state that you know, is not handleable, you can sort of throw an exception if people know better than you when you wrote the code and say, Oh, actually, like I know what causes this and I want to handle it, They can still catch it. But otherwise, like Jason is saying,
它不是编译时的，你永远不知道是什么会导致你的操作系统抛出异常，因为你可能只是被其他东西 kill -9 了，对吧？所以你永远不知道所有，其实我不知道这是否，无论如何，单独的话题，你永远不知道所有，其实我不知道这是否，无论如何，单独的话题，你永远不知道什么，信号不是异常，但我认为你有正确的精神。是的，所以你永远不知道什么可能会在运行时崩溃。同样，如果你进入某种你知道无法处理的状态，你可以抛出一个异常，如果人们比你写代码时更了解情况，并说，哦，其实，我知道是什么导致了这个，我想处理它，他们仍然可以捕获它。但否则，就像 Jason 说的，
it passes all the way up and contains the stack information. Yeah. So let me think. Other stuff. I mean, we've covered most of it. In 2018, Kotlin was the fastest growing language. So I think it shows that there was a clear demand for something else for Android.
它会一直向上传递并包含堆栈信息。是的。所以让我想想。其他事情。我的意思是，我们已经涵盖了大部分。在 2018 年，Kotlin 是增长最快的语言。所以我认为这表明对 Android 的其他东西有明确的需求。
So before 2018, so I think before 2017, there was almost no Kotlin on Android. I don't know if it wasn't supported or just it hadn't been popularized. And so in the past, I think, well, in the two or three years between 2017 and around 2019, 2020, Kotlin went from 100% backend to 50-50 backend mobile as a language. So that's huge, huge growth. And as I said, I think that's because Java is a pretty difficult language to be building a frontend. And Kotlin kind of addressed a lot of those really deep concerns. And so if you are looking to do Android development, definitely, definitely, even if you're experienced in Java, take the time to learn Kotlin. I think it would be really useful.
所以在 2018 年之前，所以我认为在 2017 年之前，Android 上几乎没有 Kotlin。我不知道它是不被支持还是只是没有普及。所以过去，我想，嗯，在 2017 年到 2019 年、2020 年左右的两三年里，Kotlin 作为一种语言从 100% 后端变成了 50% 后端 50% 移动端。所以这是巨大的，巨大的增长。正如我所说，我认为这是因为 Java 是一种构建前端相当困难的语言。而 Kotlin 解决了很多那些非常深层的问题。所以如果你正在寻找进行 Android 开发，绝对，绝对，即使你有 Java 经验，也要花时间学习 Kotlin。我认为它会非常有用。
It feels good to be back on a normal non-interview. I like the interviews, but I like this too. Yeah, this is great. Yeah, I know a lot of people have emailed us, you know, asking. I mean, a lot of people love the episodes too. I mean, it's pretty much a toss up, but, you know, as the show's grown, we do have a lot of folks emailing us asking for, you know, more of the natural episodes.
回到正常的非采访节目感觉真好。我喜欢采访，但我也喜欢这个。是的，这太棒了。是的，我知道很多人给我们发了电子邮件，你知道，询问。我的意思是，很多人也喜欢那些剧集。我的意思是，这几乎是五五开，但，你知道，随着节目的成长，我们确实有很多听众发邮件给我们，要求，你知道，更多这种自然的剧集。
And specifically, you know, they have a lot of languages they want us to cover that we haven't got to yet. I just want the sweet, sweet tool of the shows. Yeah, the tools of the show are awesome. Actually, I was going to use VC package. I found out we made that a tool of the show way back in April. And now VC package is really taking off, which is amazing. So I think we definitely called that one early. But yeah, so it's really great to be back and uh you know we're gonna find out a way to uh to do these these type of shows more often thank everyone again for their
特别是，你知道，他们有很多语言希望我们涵盖，但我们还没有涉及。我只是想要节目的甜蜜工具。是的，节目的工具太棒了。其实我本来要用 VC package。我发现我们在四月份的时候把它作为节目的工具。现在 VC package 真的火起来了，这太棒了。所以我认为我们绝对很早就预见到了这一点。但是的，所以回到这里真的很好，而且，你知道，我们会找到一种方法，更频繁地做这些类型的节目，再次感谢大家的
thank you all for your support um check us out on discord there's actually a really several really good threads going on discord you know there there was the questions chat room, which we used to answer Q&A last month. And, you know, that is just, you know, continuing. There's discussions offshooting from that. And then the on topic, which is the main room, has a lot of good content. So check us out on Discord. You know, if you have questions for us and you add us, we try our best to answer just about anything. And also talk to the other folks on Discord.
感谢大家的支持，嗯，在 Discord 上关注我们，Discord 上实际上有几个非常好的讨论串，你知道，有问答聊天室，我们上个月用它来回答问答。而且，你知道，这只是，你知道，在继续。有从那衍生出来的讨论。然后是主题讨论，也就是主房间，有很多好的内容。所以请在 Discord 上关注我们。你知道，如果你有问题要问我们并且 @ 我们，我们尽力回答几乎任何问题。也可以和 Discord 上的其他人交流。
There's a lot of really, really talented people on there. Music by Eric Barndollar. music by eric barn dollar programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution to patrick and i and share alike in kind There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
上面有很多非常有才华的人。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以进行重混、改编，但你必须向 Patrick 和我提供署名，并以相同方式共享。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。